this is jocko podcast number 350 with
echo charles and me jocko willing good
evening echo good evening
sergeant humphrey's squad secured a path
and established a position from which
they could overwatch second squad as
they re-entered friendly lines
as humphreys marines were breaking down
their overwatch position to move back to
fob increment
the rear element of the squad was pinned
in a canal by heavy and accurate machine
gun fire from taliban hidden in a tree
line
i ran to sergeant humphrey shouting
let's go we got to move on that gun
staff sergeant henley and i were
converging on sergeant humphrey as we
rushed to develop a plan to relieve the
pressure on the pinned down fire team
from the taliban machine gun i look back
to see
zach was on my heels
there would be no need for an
interpreter where i was going
he just saw me start running
and he did the same
then sergeant humphrey stepped on a
pressure plate ied
the sound and force enveloped me in a
sensation all went black
i have no idea how long i was out but
when i came to the first person i saw
was zack
he knelt beside me over me my rifle in
his hand protecting and supporting me as
i fought to my feet
i imagine we looked like a filthy
madonna and child in the moment
as zach helped me rise i looked to my
left and saw staff sergeant henley
he lay in a heap a tangle of his own
limbs himself struggling to rise
he had also been knocked out and was
shouting at me unaware that blood poured
from his own blown out eardrums
i could make no sense of what he was
saying then i saw humphrey and stopped
trying to
when i got to him sergeant humphrey's
right foot was completely blown off
all the muscle and tissue on his left
calf was gone his left thigh lay open
from a piece of shrapnel
later i would learn his jaw was broken
but for now he lay at my feet screaming
doc collins and corporal matt bland
rushed to sergeant humphrey and began
treating his grievous wounds i called in
a medevac as i held the meat of his calf
to the bone
as near crick
wrapped it
with corporal sean leahy
directing the squad's fire upon the
enemy corporal spivey swept the kill
zone for more ieds and then swept a
clear path to the point at which the
medevac aircraft would pick up humphrey
through it all sergeant humphrey
remained poised directing his own
treatment and movement
as we carried humphrey to the medevac
helicopter all i could think was
what a bad day
it was in insufficient for the moment
but it was all i could think to say
they tried to put me on the helicopter
but with staff sergeant henley and
sergeant humphrey both wounded and gone
there was no way i was leaving when we
returned to fob increment the co handed
me a towel to wipe the blood off my
hands and gear and said sergeant
humphrey is gonna lose a leg but the
surgeon says he will live
but what happened out
there looked at him and exhaled
i don't know sir
that file is deleted
there was little else to say
so i turned away and went back to
debrief of my platoon
i was tired and sad and likely consul
concussed but i had a job to do
zach always did his and more i could do
the same bringing out the collective
narrative in the debrief began to bring
back the details for me
but zack standing over me ready to kill
to protect me stood out in stark relief
from the start
that vision
zack silhouetted against the dust still
swirling from the explosion that
flattened me color and detail becoming
clearer as my consciousness returned is
what is one i still see sometimes as i
wake
it says something about zack as a man as
a battlefield interpreter and as my
friend
it was a common it was common to hear
americans say of the afghans
we can't want it more than they do
but it often seemed we did
zach was a huge exception he was not a
soldier but he was there to fight
he understood our missions in a way that
other interpreters did not
most interpreters were like specialty
items in our packs inert and just riding
along until it was time to employ them
for their purpose
but marines
are utility players capable of
addressing a wide array of circumstances
and expected to prevail in each
like a marine zach was an active member
of first platoon
he did not shy away from any danger he
did not question
doing whatever the mission demanded
because he was committed to it for
afghanistan
zanullah zaki ran to the sound of the
guns in a way that would have made
a marine infantry instructor smile
standing at the debrief talking through
what happened as is expected after every
operation i told the platoon that all of
us were going out the next day for
humphreys revenge
i thanked zack for his willingness to
always be where he might be needed
particularly when it was protecting my
life
i had already come to see zach as more
than an interpreter
but now
there was no way to call him anything
but a brother
and that right there is
[Music]
an excerpt
from a book which is called always
faithful
a story of the war in afghanistan the
fall of kabul
and the unshakeable bond between a
marine and an interpreter
and this is a book
that was written by that marine
and that interpreter
the marines name is major tom schumann
and the interpreter
an afghan national
his name is
zanula zaki
and they served together in hellmann
province
with three five marines during an
extremely violent deployment
and they had each other's back on the
ground there
and they continued to support each other
even as afghanistan fell apart and it's
an incredible story
of how all that went down and it's an
honor to have
the marine
from this story tom schuman here with us
tonight to share his experiences
and his lessons learned
from the battlefield and from life
tom thanks for coming down man
sir thanks for having me echo thanks
um and you're just right up the street
at camp pendleton that's a firm up in
san mateo on the north side of base
active duty marine currently serving and
you're the what exo operations officer
oh opso not quite exo
still on the trenches hooking and
jabbing
awesome man well thanks for coming down
and thanks to your chain of command for
allowing you to come down here for the
day i know that's not always an easy
thing to pull off but appreciate it and
i i always well everybody knows i love
the marine corps so i i appreciate that
we're getting a little love from the
marine corps today it's outstanding um
let's just get into this this is a this
is a great story well
well parts of it are a great story parts
of it are are rough
um
i like to start at the beginning kind of
figure out where you came from and
how you got to this point in your life
today so i'm gonna go to the book
it says i grew up steeped in chaos
surrounded by weak men who wouldn't
control their temper didn't consider
consequences and bullied women through
their body language or by getting even
louder than loud women
my mom did what she could to provide
stability but my childhood memories but
in my childhood memories there is a
through line of angry screaming holes
punched in walls
thrown glasses shattered
the effect of that has been for me to
seek the opposite in all things
it's almost incalculable to me that
someone does not consider consequences
i am very comfortable in chaotic
situations but control over myself and
my surroundings is second only to my
faith in christ in defining the essence
of who i am
my mom was a good kid
left to fend for herself
the south side offers a million ways to
get off track and by 13 she was feral
drinking and drugging for the remainder
of her teenage years at 17 she was
waiting tables in chicago to pay for
partying
when my father showed up on a motorcycle
with a guitar and long blonde hair he
chatted her up and played her song
she put down her order pad hopped on the
back of the bike and rode off with him
then he decided they needed to move to
georgia by 18 my mom was a pregnant high
school dropout who quit using who quit
using out of duty to me her unborn child
three years later she was married with
two kids living 800 miles away from her
family
things got bad fast my earliest memories
are of them fighting when my mom
confided in my father's sister i have to
get out of here i can't raise these kids
and all this
she agreed to take the three of us to
chicago
my mom packed three-year-old me and my
three-month-old sister jessie into my
aunt's yellow datsun hatchback and ran
back to the south side
when we got there we landed in my great
aunt's house mom called my father in
georgia
and told him we wouldn't be back
well
it's a wild way to get it all okay to
get started
yeah it was uh
wild times there to to start off and
i think
it really
ended up shaping who i am and and
and to some degree it probably helped me
professionally uh
you know this idea of
equanimity that calm in the storm and
when when there's constantly chaos and
emotion all around you
i found that i would go inside
get everything inside of me ordered and
restored
and uh
to be able to you know there's a great
line and gates of fire
by stephen pressfield where the platoon
commander
die nikes
he talks about the the role of the
officer is self-composure
and it's the it's to fire your troops
when they when they won't go forward and
it's to reign them in when they've when
they've gone blind to rage and so this
this idea of self-composure
was
really a survival
mechanism for me early uh but it
translated later on into
i think being helpful professionally and
and uh just to me
men who cannot
uh
men who
resort to physical intimidation
or to raising their voice
is it's weakness
uh it's cowardice
and uh and and if you can't
logically compel someone with with
at a conversational tone of your point
then you probably don't have a very good
argument
or maybe you're just talking to the
wrong person you know and so
uh yeah it it definitely shaped me but i
i think
when we're talking about cowardice i
think
we can juxtapose that with courage and
that's my mom's courage
to have me when she was 19.
i mean
i look back and i reflect on that
decision often
that how scared she must have been the
uncertainty
and and for her to go
through with it and to bring me into
this world at 19 i i
i will always uh just be so grateful uh
for her courage there and um
and then the same thing just to
what every parent wants for their child
is is an opportunity
and you're going to see that you know
when we start to talk about zach and and
what he did towards the end of this book
and
and she understood that the
that the best
way for us to have an opportunity was
again required courage
she's 22 years old two little kids
and drives 800 miles back to chicago
with
nothing and uh um but it's a conviction
and and
so yeah real really that was my first
example of courage is is my mom
yeah the um
as far as
one thing i talk a lot about with
leaders is
you you're basically there's a mob right
your team is a mob whether it's a
platoon whether it's a troop whether
it's a sales team it's a mob
and just like any other mob like they
can get going in a certain direction
and
your job as a leader is to make sure
that the direction that the mob is going
is correct
and the two classic examples kind of
ones you you mentioned a little bit but
my team does great right we go out and
do a great mission and everything goes
smooth that mob mentality can be hey
look we're unstoppable we don't need to
we don't need to rehearse very much we
don't need to worry about planning
because we're so good
you as a leader need to go actually hey
we did good but here's some things we
can improve here's what we got to watch
out for
so you got to go pull the opposite
direction of the mob the other time is
like oh you go out the mission goes
sideways it goes bad and you can feel
the mob start to get dragged down and
then it's your job to as leaders say hey
yup we made some mistakes we paid for it
but here's what we're gonna do to fix it
next time so that idea of
and look there's some times where the
mob is going in the right direction you
can just yeah that's the easy that's the
fun part of being a leader the the mob's
going the right direction you get to
just cheer them on and say hell yeah
uh
so that's a very important thing to pay
attention to you can't do that if you're
getting emotional you just can't you'll
be in the mob and in the mob is not the
place for you to be in a leadership
situation yeah the yelling thing i think
it's one of the one of the interesting
stereotypes that
the military has the stereotype that you
you yell and scream to get things done
part of it's because of boot camp movies
right
how many times have you watched the
first 45 minutes of full metal drackett
right i mean
it's just that's oh that must be the way
leadership is and it's and as you and i
both know there's plenty of leaders
inside the military that
that that do yell and they do scream
and that goes back to the book the uh
psychology of military incompetence and
what what attracts the military to
people like that and attracts people
like that to the military but you know
always have a an interesting you know
with a guy that worked for me and wrote
these books with me leif babin you know
he's he's worked for me you know for 18
months work up deployment and then we've
been working together for another 15
years or something like that and he
he'll always ask a crowd of people you
know how often do you think jocko yells
at me
and you know
you know depending on how much the
people know about me yo oh he must yell
you all time he's like he's actually
never yelled i've never yelled at him
one time and leif usually gives the
caveat that he gave me plenty of times
where i probably wanted to yell at him
but it's just bad leadership and
again uh the same thing you just said
if i can't convince you of my idea my
idea is probably not that great
and your ideas
either that or my idea is not that much
greater than yours so my default as well
let's just go with yours that's easier
that's it's gonna it's gonna make
everything more efficient effective
um
so
going back to the story here so you're
this chapter
as soon as i as soon as i got this
chapter the chapter is called a hippie
cop's
son
so
you being the son your mom being the
hippie cop
talk to us through the transition of
your mom going from being a hippie
that's that's jumping on the back of a
chopper with a random dude with long
hair and going to georgia
and having kids to coming back here and
you know and plus you mentioned you know
she was drinking at a young age doing
drugs and all of a sudden she does like
a 180
and she becomes a cop what was that all
about
yeah i don't think the hippie part ever
fully transitioned uh i think it was she
was duty-bound
and uh she
and the duty was you and your sister yes
and so she didn't
grow up with her dream job being a
chicago cop it was uh there was health
insurance and she had two hungry babies
and uh and that was who was hiring and
so i i think yeah the if
if you talk to my mom today that that
hippie part of her is still alive and
well
and uh was never quite
uh subordinated by the uh her time as a
cop but um the hippie comes out quite a
bit as you're going in the marine corps
you're going in
[Music]
it comes out sorry mom for sure and so
yeah my mom had two rules you know don't
don't join the military and uh
don't get motorcycle
did both and then uh crashed motorcycle
and have had quite a
interesting marine corps career but uh
yeah i it was it was simply
um a matter of necessity and duty for
her children so that that's why she
became a cop not not because she
you know was watching bad boys bad boys
or whatever you know the 90s uh that was
not a it was it was yeah and and i
imagine single mom
being a cop that's
i mean how the hell does that even work
yeah what kind of hours is she working
she's small lady too you know she's tiny
uh and she's a cop in chicago in the 90s
it was tough tough gig uh but at the end
of the day she she
had something that she was serving that
was bigger than herself and uh and
and service
always
comes at a cost
or it's not service you know and service
always hurts and if it doesn't hurt to
some extent you know then then again i
would argue maybe it's not service and
so
i i think uh
she's working nights uh on the south
side of chicago in the 90s and uh kind
of raised by a village there as a kid
getting passed off between my aunt my
grandmother you know and and but a
little collective effort there but yeah
it was
you know all my mom my sister and i all
slept in the same bed for like the first
five six years when we got back in a
room in my aunt's house i mean it was uh
it was tough
meanwhile as that's going on your
dad ends up going to jail when you're
eight years old
how's that go down
yeah i uh i was still visiting him uh
during the summers
uh for a couple years after we went back
to chicago i'd still go down there for
the summer and then uh just
one summer i wasn't going and um
and yeah i think he was
something with drug drug related um
and i what's tough for me
about that
when i think about my dad i i look at
pictures of me when i'm a kid and i and
i'm the age four five you know six years
old
and i think you know you've got a choice
and you got this little kid this little
boy
and uh
how could you not choose him
and that's like what will sometimes to
this day when i when i just come across
and
this and and now that i've got my
daughter just turned four you know and i
and i just think
i will
always choose you
and um
there's that
a boy needs a dad
period and uh and my mom was super mom
and she did she taught me how to throw
football and she played catch with me
she was not my dad
and uh
and that
that was something that uh
you know go you you don't want to go to
the father-son
banquet
with your friend's dad
and uh
fortunately i had you know some some
guys who some of my friends dads who
looked after me but uh that that took a
long time to
distill i'm still kind of probably
working through some of that um but yeah
he got out of jail um
when i was about to graduate junior high
and i went back for the first time to
see him but uh
yeah
that absence um
was painful and
yeah
yeah you you describe it in here um
going back to the book here
you say i followed my mom into a room
after dinner
and sat there while she tried to
decompress from her day
she was folding clothes and she tried to
talk to me i was non-responsive she
looked me straight in the eye
thomas tell me what's wrong
i was suddenly crying so hard i couldn't
stand i lay on the floor i just want a
dad i said over and over through the
gasps and sobs
eventually my best friend's dad started
taking me to the father-son events he
wasn't my father but at least i was with
a man who cared about me i want an
autographed picture of chicago bear's
wide receiver tom waddle at one father
and son banquet
winning that eight by ten black and
white head shot capped off the best
night of my life then my best friend's
dad
hung himself in his garage
my father was in prison three states
away my supplemental father figure
killed himself and most of the men in my
life were unaccountable it made me
mistrustful of men and it also left me
such that now when i perceive a void or
a gap
i feel a compulsion to fill it to make
it better
put less positively i'm unable to resist
trying to bend a situation to my will
i've never been the smartest or most
talented guy in any room i've been in
but i am relentless
for better or for worse
yeah as i was reading this we'll get to
some of these parts where you are um
determined a little too determined with
the kind of determination that'll get
you in trouble it's the kind of thing
when you have kids and you're like oh my
this kid's pissing me off and you
realize oh that's because it's a strong
willed kid and you actually want those
things you actually want those things
uh you mentioned your dad got out of
jail when you're 13 years old
and this sounds and when you talk about
in the book this is sort of like um
kind of a little bit of like sounds like
you're living the dream a little bit
you're down there in georgia for the
summers you got horses you got four
wheelers you got jet skis
and you're working hard
so
that that was like a good experience
you're learning a lot definitely a
little best of both worlds going to grow
up run wild in the alleys of chicago
that's kind of where we hung out in the
alleys playing basketball playing
whatever getting into trouble and then
yeah the summers i get to be a little
pretend cowboy and ride a horse almost
fall off it you know crash a
four-wheeler go out on the lake uh so
yeah it was a it was a nice little blend
to kind of get to experience both things
and
undoubtedly i
i did learn some things about hard work
uh working for my dad um
i worked for him for
four years until i was 16
like all summer and uh
my 16th birthday said you know you've
throughout the these last four years
you've saved up enough to get a car
um
you got a 1985 nissan maxima wagon with
250 000 miles on it hell yeah uh so like
definitely appreciate learn learn to
appreciate hard work and uh so that
there was some there was some good
lessons learned and you did uh
you went to an evangelical christian
camp down there yeah
and
you know uh south side of chicago is all
italian and irish and very catholic
and uh so i was kind of raised in and
around
the catholic church
my dad was southern baptist i went to
the southern baptist camp and
uh very different i was going to say
that that's very different
definitely definitely different but uh
you know i i the most important day of
my life happened during that camp and
that's uh when i accepted jesus christ
my savior and
undoubtedly uh
that
camp and that moment
i'm only here today because
of
um that encounter and and and
to be i've always had a father you know
and so i i've always
men in the church you know may abandon
you uh i've always had a father and that
father has
you know when we talk about the title
always faithful that that's always
faithful and so
uh in my darkest
hope most hopeless moments there was
always little light of hope and
and that's thanks to
what what started that day when i was 14
years old down on jekyll island at a
baptist church camp
i'm i'm talking a little bit about just
because the way you said that but also
because you may have been uh born again
but you
you're not a saint at this point by by
any stretch we'll get into some of that
stuff
um you you may not have
been always walking the enlightened path
along the way that's a fair assessment
uh
so you roll into high school and you're
six to
140 pounds
which i didn't i was 100 sure that was
possible echo charles assessment yeah
that's fantastic
so
what's what's your deal in high school
what are you thinking about what's going
on in high school
um riding the bench playing football uh
you know i i was basically six 240
pounds in seventh grade so i was the big
uh and then just
never
no no additional development there uh
but i
i knew i wanted to get out
i knew i was getting somewhere
and i knew that the chaos
and the dysfunction of my childhood that
i was
getting out
and initially i viewed that as you go to
college is how you get out of this
situation
uh no one in my family had been to
college but i knew that my friends who
seemed to have more stability like their
parents went to college and so
that that was really the the goal and
then i i thought you know i i don't know
what
jobs professional jobs are i know there
are doctors
and lawyers
and so like i know i'm not going to be a
doctor so that means i could be a lawyer
and uh and so i would i would do the
debate team yeah you each team yeah you
went full nerd right is that is that a
national honor society drama club speech
and debate team treasurer of the service
club
president of the ecology club yeah you
went full money that's the hippie mom
part so i got the president of the
ecology club plus my ap bio teacher was
the and i wasn't doing too well in ap
bio so uh
i uh yeah uh is this a catholic school
yes
boys only yes all boys yeah
how was that
loved it it was a blast i mean it's
there's no egos there's nobody trying to
impress anybody it's just
guys being dudes and
having like uh
it was a ton of fun absolutely wearing a
uniform every day yes
where'd your mom get money for this
school yeah so she took out a loan
her first second mortgage for the house
uh
for us
to go
to school
and that's why i always
felt like i had to honor you know her
sacrifice because
uh
she's working her ass off and making all
these you know sacrifices that i i felt
you know in turn a duty and obligation
to her
and so i took my studies really
seriously in high school and i
was was was doing whatever i could to to
make sure that um
her investment in in me was was there
would be a return on it and so that's
part of why i was in all these clubs um
but yeah i i i thought i'll go to
college i'll be a lawyer and
then i'll be able to take care of
everybody and that's kind of what i was
thinking in high school
now september 11th happens what what
year are you in a sophomore sophomore
did that start to
make you think about
joining the military
it's why i'm in the military it it it
made me think uh you know at that point
it was still the age of innocence or
ignorance you didn't know that at least
i didn't know that there were bad people
in the world who wanted to do the us
harm
and
so it was initially very confusing
but by the end of that day
i knew at some point
i'll do something about that
and so i knew i'd serve i didn't know i
joined the marine corps i didn't even
probably know there was a branch called
the marine corps and i wasn't
gi joe i wasn't you know didn't have a
dad in house wasn't doing like man stuff
uh i just knew like hey
somebody's got to do something about
that
you should do that and and that has
put me on a trajectory of
where i am sitting here today
so
you apply to college you get into uh
loyola university chicago
is that a good school i don't even know
i'm sorry it's all right yeah it's
pretty good pretty good school yeah
pretty good school hard to get into
i i don't i mean
i think maybe they're gonna your alma
mater is gonna come at you yeah you'd be
like hell yeah it's hard to get yeah
it's super hard to get into it's a leap
uh
so you get in there you're you're kind
of stoked but you don't have any money
to pay for college and this is where you
first kind of discover
nrotc
yep
yeah uh it's the ivy league of the
midwest um there we go okay uh yeah i
you know no one is is
no one i'm not able to talk to kind of
anybody about going to college uh i
don't know anything about going to
college and so
well after all the scholarship
applications are already passed and well
after i'm like oh like okay so i'm into
college
like how am i gonna pay for it and uh
and so i
goog well there wasn't google on aol
uh you know looking up
college scholarships and i find that uh
that there's this thing called rotc and
that they pay for your tuition and i
said well i want to serve anyways
um
this could be a thing and and when i
call them they're like yeah the
scholarship window closed like six
months ago but you could do it for free
and uh and maybe if you're if in a
couple years you can you can pick up the
scholarship and i thought well i got no
other nothing else going for me so i'll
i'll try this and uh so that's how i
ended up in rotc it sounds like you were
a little unimpressed in the book with
the navy when you
like what you had in your mind for what
military service would be like and you
showed up in the navy who didn't really
impress you too much at the rotc branch
at loyola chicago sure i i
the only thing i i still kind of thought
i'd be a lawyer
and uh and my grandma had a big
uh crush on tom cruise so i'd seen him
oh a few good men dude and so i think
well
that'll make it happen right there right
yeah and so
my mom is really against it but she
thinks oh well you're going to be tom
cruise in this movie it's not a bit it's
maybe not terrible and then i go to my
little rotc orientation week and we go
up to great lakes naval base
and uh getting marched around and yelled
at and it's just it's just clear like
the the marine staff the navy staff and
then the the midshipmen who are first
class who are going to commission the
marine corps and we're gonna i just said
i don't know but it looks like these
guys have
these guys have something that this
other group
doesn't and uh
so i think i want to go and so that was
my
still not knowing anything about the
marine corps not knowing what infantry
was not knowing
expeditionary none of this kind of stuff
i just know that like it seems like they
got their [__] together and i want to be
like those guys he picked colonel jessup
earlier
yeah you know that i had a conversation
with a good friend of mine who's a who's
a regular navy guy
and he he said something you know we are
he's deeply involved with the the seal
community now
but
we just had a quick conversation about
you know like the navy
versus the seal teams because
when people go to buds if they don't
make it through buds they're in the navy
and the job for someone that wants to go
to buds
that doesn't make it and ends up in the
navy is not the job that they're looking
for if you go into the army and you want
to be a special force soldier and you
don't make it cool you can be a rifleman
in the 82nd airborne 101st airborne or
that's still an outstanding job and
you're doing
something proximal to what you want to
do the navy is not like that
and he said well you know that makes
makes it sound like my job was horrible
and i said no not at all it's just that
there's certain people that are
attracted to certain jobs and i told
them this story that i've told a hundred
times about i'm on
an lpd you know amphibious ship out here
off the coast of san diego we're 30
miles off of pendleton we're about to go
do a hydrographic reconnaissance the
freaking waves are huge it's raining and
miserable
and
i'm standing i'm standing there getting
these you know getting ready to launch
our zodiacs off the back of this lpd and
this bosun's mate
first class and it's you know it's
whatever 10 o'clock at night storms
and he looks at me and he looks out
there and he looks back at me and he
goes man i'm glad i don't have your job
and i looked back at him and i said well
i'm glad i don't have yours so there you
go like everyone's got their own little
thing
so that's why when you look at people
that are in navy rotc they're a
different type of person than the type
of per there's people that look at
marines and go oh hell no i'm not doing
that because they look at the navy
people like oh they look like they're
going to be doing some finance and some
working on engine engineers and like
this kind of thing it's just it's just
propensity of job that people want and
you looked at the navy guys and said
they look like they're going to be
engineers and these guys over here look
like they're going to carry machine guns
and you're a machine gun carrying type
of dude
a firm
so uh
but you still have so you still don't
have a scholarship yet so you're at this
point you're working at costco you're
tying you're changing tires which is a
rewarding job
yeah someone brings you something that's
damaged broken and then you give it back
to him and it works again
and i thought this was cool you you had
a guy so now it's your junior year and
your gunny gunny steel
tells you that your grades your grades
aren't good enough for a for a
scholarship and he says you know what
you better do is you better go to this
platoon leaders class
so explain though explain the platoon
leaders class
there are a couple different ways to
commission as an officer you can go to
um
the academies are one commissioning
source you can do it through rotc and
then there's you can do it through occ
meaning you've already graduated college
and you can just do a little 10 week
thing or you can kind of hit two summers
during college year through this platoon
leaders class course plc
and so you do two six week hits
and uh so since i still didn't have a
scholarship going into my junior year
and i wanted to be a marine
i was advised that this was probably the
route i would need to go
and so
i went to what's called plc juniors and
uh
it was a very good learning experience
we talked about learning experiences
where we started today
yes we did and uh people still learning
all the time sure
and uh
and it and you know i'm so jacked up
like you know more effed up than a
football bat as they'll say you know i i
probably needed um
an extra go and so i think ultimately
there's there's a lot of benefit in that
six weeks but
uh and i think my gunnery sergeant
recognized that i probably could use a
little extra training and so i think he
withheld some information there
uh
until
graduation rehearsal
and uh he said you know it's human you
had the scholarship i just uh didn't
tell you so
congratulations
so instead of spending six weeks hanging
out with your friends or whatever you
spent six weeks doing marine corps stuff
yep donna quantico was that a quantico
yep how was that course
when i went 2006 it was uh it was tough
uh i don't want to tell you know too
many ocs war stories because i'll get
heckled uh but uh i i thought it was it
was this guy colonel chase used to stand
at the top of the hill and just say like
quit canada you shouldn't be here you're
worthless like
and then when i went back you know seven
it was a new ceo and and i think we the
surge was happening so we needed to make
sure people got through and so it
i'll tell you you know
one thing that
i'll never you know i'll always remember
from that 06 is i had this mean as hell
sergeant instructors ifo he was a mean
mean man and uh every night we would
hold the m16 by the front side tip
between our thumb and our index finger
fully extended straight forward and he
would say
discipline is and we scream instant
willingness and obedience to orders and
say discipline is
instant willingness and obedience to
orders and so we just do that over and
over again and i've
i've always uh
thought you know that's that's shaped
how i think about discipline and
you know
close order drill is the most
basic form of discipline it's it's it's
the most rudimentary
basic form of discipline that we have
that we build off
in the military and then there's then
you do battle drills which are another
form of discipline you do immediate
action drills another kind of it's all
all this ties into just instant
willingness and obedience to orders a
drill
is so that you you don't have to think
about it you know and so thumb clip
twist pull pin frag out right and so
that's
a battle drill or contact left and it
and it's all predicated
on
a drill something that you do over and
over again until it becomes less
thinking and
and
when you why do you do this it reduces
the need of physical courage when
something is drilled into you it's
you're not relying so much on your
physical courage in that moment
uh
and and what i what i've been thinking
about as i
continue my career in the marine corps
is
is when you become more senior
you actually need a lot more discipline
than when you're pfc or last corporal or
junior officer
when you are a pfc or or junior in the
organization so much your life is
dictated to you so there's not a lot of
opportunity to do
things that are undisciplined and and
and
as you become senior you have
more opportunity to discern
what you
what routes you want to go
and the thing is that as you get more
latitude or more freedom
you
have the potential
to be less disciplined and i think when
you think of the hard thing
is usually the right thing and the right
thing is usually the hard thing
and as as you advance in this
organization it requires you to have
discipline to continue to do
the hard and right thing
and it's not that you would do the wrong
thing
you would just do the less right thing
and and so
i can just cut this little corner and be
like well you know like i've been here
for 15 years like do i really need to do
like
i'll generally kind of get it in the box
but i don't have to like do all these
little
and so
i find that
that discipline
uh
in your habits and your actions and in
your thoughts
that helps you because otherwise you're
relying on moral courage
and so if physical courage if you rely
less on physical courage through battle
drills and immediate action drills and
close order drill
you you rely less on moral courage when
you have disciplined thoughts habits and
actions in your life and and so that
that way it's not i don't have to say i
don't need to put myself in in a
position where
my moral courage has to carry the day
for me to do get up in the morning to
like my boss like we have to be at work
at 6 30 p.t
no one's checking if i'm there at 6 30
like i'm the opposite i could probably
come in at 6 40 6 45 you know and but
by having the discipline of getting up
when my alarm goes off at 5 a.m every
day i reduce the need to have the moral
courage to kind of make that decision
and same thing with you know if you
don't put ice cream in your freezer
it's not a matter of discipline at that
point it's i had the discipline not to
buy it at the store because otherwise if
it's in the freezer every time i walk by
the fridge it's a matter of moral
courage do i have the moral courage
you're talking to necklace world right
now to do this thing or not echo also
equates moral courage with uh avoiding
the ice cream you know it's it's always
surprising uh or not always but a lot of
times people are surprised that in basic
seal training you have weekends off you
go do whatever you want you can
you can do whatever you want you can go
get drunk you can go party you can
you can get crazy
and that's part of the test because once
you're in the sale teams there's there's
literally no one cares if you're
showing up to pt now if you go out on a
rock hump and you can't hang you're
gonna get destroyed but they want people
that find that that that will discipline
themselves that have the self-discipline
because and that's there's been plenty
of people that didn't make it through
seal training because they were because
they didn't want to
have discipline on the weekends just to
do what they should be doing and said
they wouldn't did what they wanted to do
so that that's interesting the other
thing is
man as you get older and you get more
senior and you can start cutting some
corners
[Music]
every single person
below you in the chain of command can
see it and this is that where i got very
lucky because i was uh
i was pry enlisted so i was the youngest
and most junior guy in my first two
platoons which thank god what a what a
freaking incredible opportunity
but
i would watch
my platoon chief i would watch my
platoon commander
and if they were three minutes late i
was tracking it if they forgot a piece
of gear i was tracking it if they needed
a little extra something to get need a
little help getting up the ladder i was
tracking it so when i moved into a
leadership position i always felt those
eyes man i felt those eyes all the time
and i didn't want to let those guys down
so so that's something that always
weighed on me and then the last thing
you know when we when we start talking
about
you know immediate action drills and
battle drills what's really awesome is
because sometimes people think oh well
so what you have is a bunch of robots
you know you've trained a bunch of
robots just do whatever you say no
actually you get these battle drills
down you get people
it's like do you play any musical
instruments negative
uh so
guitar
which i play i'm not good at it but
jimmy page who played for the band led
zeppelin
echo charles we good okay
he was a studio musician for years which
meant he went into a student he was very
well known as a studio meaning they
would tell him exactly what to play and
he would play the notes that they wanted
him to play and he did that for for for
forever just highly disciplined
mechanical playing of the instrument
and that's how he made a living for a
long time
and because he had all that discipline
because he knew every fret and every
note and how to bend them and how to how
to manipulate them he knew them so well
that when he
got into led zeppelin now all of a
sudden he could take those things and
break rules
so what you end up with like in a sealed
platoon
especially like a new guy in a seal
platoon they're they're a robot for a
little while you want to make sure that
their weapons always painted
point-and-safe direction they know
exactly where the other people are
during a during an immediate action
drill that they're
doing the safe thing so you drill them
so it becomes mechanical
and then once they start getting it now
all of a sudden they can start saying
wait i know i'm supposed to be over here
but i can provide better cover
for my other squad if i
s scurry up this little this little
mound of dirt a little bit and it's
still in a safe zone because i'm not
getting in front of it i'm not cutting
cutting off anyone's field of fire so
boom and so you even have the the front
line shooters the new guys after a
little while they're starting to think
but they know the rules they know the
rules so well that they can really think
they can go right to the edge of that
box
they can go they can go right up to the
edge of that berm that they know if they
go any further they're going to cut off
someone else's field of fire they know
that so you get them so well trained and
so well disciplined that they end up
with a bunch of freedom and then that
goes all the way up the chain now the
guys that have got two platoons under
the belt they can start making little
adjustments with their whole fire team
and then eventually you get a platoon
commander that goes oh
here's the rule right now
and here's what i should do but i
actually see something that i can do
that doesn't break the rules but it
bends them and it's going to give us a
better opportunity to get a bigger bite
on on this on this battlefield right now
so those immediate action drills and
like close order drill boom like we are
doing without thinking and you've got to
have that
but then when you get to the actual
immediate action drills people start to
understand the concepts of what we're
doing and then they understand the
parameters you know there's certain
certain notes on a guitar
if you play this note then you play this
other note it's not it doesn't work
literally doesn't work the whole world
will go that sounds like [__] like
everyone will think that
so when a guy's good at iads or good at
moving through a mountain environment
when they're good at it they understand
oh i can do this right here i can
actually play this note i can play this
note over here i can bend that note
here's something i can't play that note
over there it's not going to work and
that's what we want we want people we
want thinking shooters we want people
that are understand that are so
disciplined
that they can actually have more freedom
out there and and that's what always is
the goal you know
um and in the beginning
that means we need to be highly
disciplined and never you know when
you're going through basic seal training
if you make a tiny mistake
it's it's it's like you're getting
swarmed by instructors
they do not want you to make the like
you will not sweep someone
you will not you give give a seal that's
you know in his first splatoon give him
a squirt gun
and you give him that squirt gun and
he's gonna like immediately have the
best muzzle discipline that you've ever
seen like he won't point it at his kid
to score to be like it's like a physical
like yeah i can't point this squirt gun
at my son because it just doesn't feel
right
that's how like ingrained it is and
that's what you want that discipline is
embedded in their brains
and then
over time they go okay now i have such a
good foundation to work with my mind can
be free
yep that's the goal
uh
so you got some of that stuff drilled
into you i'm gonna i'm gonna jump into
the book here for a second in my senior
year with a scholarship
i was over the hump money-wise but there
was a new problem
my metabolism slowed down and my regular
diet of pizza and beer suddenly started
yielding different results on my
permanent perennial
skinny frame i wasn't prepared for the
metabolic cost of
that in the appearance is reality marine
corps where fitness is a virtue
superseding most flaws in the core
fatness is an unpardonable sin
gunny steel again took me on as as a
personal mission he was a
picture-perfect marine thin haircut high
and tight multiple meritorious
promotions because he was genuinely
squared away marine i still kept my eyes
peeled for him whenever i was at
northwestern trying to avoid him and
heavy objects
but one day he called me on my cell
phone there was no avoiding him he
ordered me to come to his office that
was never good this was no different
schumann
[Music]
you might let yourself become a fat
piece of [__] but i ain't we ain't
commissioning a pig to lead marines
normally i would have at least offered
ii gunny but i was stunned into silence
he continued you're going to come here
come in here every morning for pt after
that you're going to have a uniform
inspection every day every day of your
life is going to be the worst day your
life until you conform to standards boom
there you go
yeah i was lacking some discipline for
sure and uh it caught up to me and and
we talked about again before we started
about how good friends tell you what you
need to hear
and uh nobody told me i was getting fat
uh so i don't want to like not take
accountability for my own fatness uh but
like i didn't think
it was possible you know i'd always been
a rail ski like it when i would go up in
waist size i was like
guess this is time for new pants like it
was nothing was clicking that i was
getting fat and you're like the slow bro
the boiling frog right that doesn't
notice that the water's exactly like it
looks like a size 42. yeah
and uh
he uh he got me squared away yeah i had
one of my friends um
he's in the seal teams and he had a guy
that was
and that was not to standards and he
brought him into his office and says hey
bro there's no fat seals and you're fat
and it ain't you're gonna start taking
the prt until you're good to go so
sometimes that direct approach what prt
physical readiness test which
again in the seal teams there's not
there's not but there's not a bunch of
people tracking you
and
there was years that go by where the guy
a guy can if you know oh i had a trip
wasn't there for the prt because like a
command like the seal team would do one
prt a year you know and you'd see it you
know months in advance like oh the prt
is on october 15th or whatever so if a
guy's like cool i'm taking leave or i'm
gonna go on a trip october 15th he's not
there you do that three years in a row
your pants size could be a 46. you know
what i'm saying well what what is it
though like a performance
or a physical it's like a
three-mile run
push-ups pull-ups swim something like
that so technically you could get gain a
bunch of weight still pass that thing
and be good to go or what you could but
you probably wouldn't be able to pass it
if and you know it's weird too like this
goes back and forth the navy has a prt
the regular navy and the seals
for a while use the navy prt but that
one you could probably could be out of
shape like from a seal
perspective and still be able to pass so
then the seals made their own prt
that just to make sure you don't have
anybody that's uh that's not you know
because there's no fat shields like just
to enforce that rule without having to
tell anybody like here's the prt if you
don't pass it you got to get on the run
program homie yeah but it's not like the
kind they're you're measuring body fat
or nothing like this and be like hey
you're over you know 14 or whatever
it's like we do have that as well oh
if you're out of there there are height
and weight standards
and every year you're supposed to get
height and weight and if and if you
don't make weight you get taped and if
you're not within tape then you get put
on the bcp program what we call and
basically you're the on the fat body
program and you've got to do weekly
check-ins and what's
they measure your to get your body fat
percentage so they'll measure like your
waist your chest your arms
that kind of exhale
echoes wonder if there's a way to get
involved in that
could i do a pose down no i mean i
like the the body weight i got taped my
whole career yeah because if you're like
if you're bigger and stronger
you're going to get taped because you
know like for me the max body weight or
for something for a guy that's 5 11 was
like you know 178
or something maybe like 182 or something
like that and i would i weighed 225.
yeah and so they'd tape you and they'd
go yeah you're just you're just a big
stronger also it's probably like a ratio
then it's not like hey your waist is
over this therefore you're out kind of
yeah because you know you get these
bigger guys who can you know they can do
the prt yeah yeah and but they're yeah
225 235
but they can perform at that you know
like you can't measure it like that you
know or it's like oh but you're
overweight
doesn't make sense yeah no they have a
ratio and then
i never like had any issue with the tape
at all i mean it was like good to go
what about the prt ever had issues no
prt good to go right now good to go no
you got to be
if you work out regularly you're going
to you're going to pass the prt so
you got to be a slacker dude and like
they're not that kind of this is a rare
dude in the seal teams that just give up
on work
i mean you're not wearing a shirt like
87 of the time yeah like if you're not
in the field you're not wearing a shirt
so if you're you know you're walking
around every day and you're just putting
on the lbs
there's not too many occasionally it
happens occasionally it happens but most
of the time and not to mention like the
actual
physical part of the job
if you're not in good shape you're going
to get fired like if you can't go out
and walk around the desert
with you know 100 pounds and do it and
hang you're you're going to get fired
you won't be in a platoon so no and
i guess you don't want to be in a seal
platoon
which is a weird thing to even be right
at that point for sure
so
you got on the run program yep gunny
steel straightened your ass out for a
second time sure did we appreciate we
appreciate him love him this is the this
is the uh the non-commissioned officers
that that make the that make the marine
corps what it is make the navy what it
is
make the military what it is absolutely
by keeping the young
in line and often the seniors as well
yeah
um
you seen up graduating which is awesome
and you had to get lasik eye surgery
so you get commissioned they cover that
but that that makes it a little time for
you to go to
the basic school
now at the basic school are you still
thinking you still might be tom cruise
at this point it seems like in the book
you were still thinking it could be tom
cruise no uh you've got to go into that
with a law contract okay so pilots and
lawyers aren't competing at the base of
school they've already got their their
contracts ahead of time got it i didn't
know
what i wanted to be when i was heading
into the basic school it i it's in there
i don't know yeah i i discovered pretty
quickly what i wanted to be field
exercise one right that's what changed
your mind yes tell us about field
exercise what
so you know even though i got to do
little summers with my dad and pretend
to be a cowboy i still didn't know
anything about being outside i didn't
know how to camp i didn't know how to
and uh
we we go out we our class picked up in
uh october so our first field exercise
is in sometime in mid mid-november
and it got down to five degrees
and uh
everybody's canteens were frozen no one
knew like put the canteen upside down or
put in your sleeping bag with you like
you tried to bite in the mres like
breaking your teeth off like uh all our
like cold weather gear is super old
sucks and like don't know how to layer
don't know anything about how to live
outside in the cold at least the
majority of us
and so uh
you know up into that point everybody
kind of talks about oh we're going to be
infantry i'm going to be infantry you're
going to be in between at that point i
know what i wanted to do like tanks
sound cool or this sounds cool like
artillery sounds cool
uh
but at the end of effects one fielder
size one
uh no
no one wanted to be infantry anymore and
uh i was just like well [__] if
you all don't want to do that
that makes me want to do that and so
it's kind of like just a response to my
environment when people don't want a
challenge or people don't i want to i
want the opposite and so
i was like well now i do want to be
infantry and
and that's
that was my
i did i still had no idea what that
actually meant beyond that it was a
response to what other people didn't
want um it wasn't until i got out in the
woods that i knew uh at adam josh course
i said yes
yes this is the right place but it that
was still to come and how was the basic
school for you
it you know they call like the big suck
uh i mean it was it was uh
it was challenging it was not like
extremely
challenging it was it was more a grind
than anything it's just six months is a
long time
and uh and so
i think
i've gone back to quantico a couple
times when i've taken the midshipmen
down there and i've got to talk to some
of the instructors and see their their
poi down there now i think it's i think
it's really good
um
it was just long it was long that's what
it was now when you're going through
that are you getting is it like ranger
school you like get put in a leadership
position in a patrol you take it out you
get graded then the next one you're a
machine gunner the next one you're a
point man
yep so you're getting good experience in
the field sure yeah you there's there's
several field exercises everybody's
getting rotated through leadership
billets and uh you know the the goal is
to to make
every marine officer
able to lead a basic rifle platoon
that's that's the intent of putting
we're the only service that that puts
you know our pilots and our lawyers and
our agitants all through this this
course where they're we're going out
training as riflemen mm-hmm every
marine's rifleman um
was it hard to get selected for infantry
yeah so it but
by the time selection came down i i
don't know what's uh like 300
uh in a in a one class alpha company
and um i think there's maybe 30 40
infantry slots uh out of that and
i i mean i remember you you were i was
first platoon and we were when the sbc
the platoon commander was reading out
who got what mos
uh there was a dude who was solid his
dad was a sergeant major and and he
didn't get it i thought oh well he's
like
way more squared away than me uh maybe
maybe i'm not going to get it um
so yeah i i think it was competitive uh
for sure is that because like the talent
spread thing yeah so it's top third
middle third bottom third so that you
have a quality spread
across
that that
that right there
that concept is what shows you that the
marine corps puts the marine corps first
it really is
so
what it is echo charles is when you go
to the basic school
you'd think number one guy would get the
number one pick what does he want to do
number two guy get the number two pick
but then
everyone would pick the the jobs like
the good jobs the cool jobs
and the people at the bottom would get
you know whatever is considered a crappy
job
so instead what they do is they cut the
class up into thirds
the first guy in the first group gets
the first pick
the first guy in the second group
so out of 100 this guy might be the
hundredth or the hundred and first guy
is that right yeah no the 201st guy gets
the second pick the 301st guy gets the
third pick so you end up with this
quality
getting spread through all the different
jobs in the marine corps so it's not
like there's some category of of marines
of marine officers that are all just
like oh they're just like the the lowest
ranking guys are just terrible no it's
you get an even spread across the board
and that is a thing that tells you that
the marine corps
puts the marine corps the whole marine
corps first that is one of the clearest
indicators in history
that we want uh everyone in the marine
corps to have an opportunity and the
marine corps comes first oh yeah wait so
what do they base that on like the
yeah throughout the six months it's
academic there's a leadership score
there's a pt score rifle score so
there's there's several kind of scores
that are calculated into your overall
class ranking largely academic but
definitely like leadership evaluations
uh all kind of i i always say like
i i only think that i i got it because
um we were in the defense
and the ground was frozen
and my spc and i was a machine gunner
and i just had a pickaxe and i was right
next to a tree with big roots
and he and he walked by and
hitting this ground and literally not
just the shovels bouncing off he's like
what are you what are you trying to do
there sherman i'm getting a chest deep
fighting hole sir
not on that ground you're not like
chuckled and walked away
uh several hours later comes by how's
that going schumann i'm like two inches
deep he's like like just uh i'm away sir
and then by day three
he goes by and he's like this guy's
maybe just stubborn enough to be a grunt
yeah because i'm sitting in a chesty
fight home and uh
i always think like maybe that's i think
that's my how i got selected dude i've
got this story from hackworth that i
read the other day
and i got to like do more with it but
he's in korea
and
he's
freezing
and he wants to go home
and
he figures out a plan in in like when
the sun goes down he starts to freeze
he's like i'm out of here how can i get
out of here so what he plans to do is
he's going to dig a hole
big enough
to put his leg in
and then he's going to toss a grenade
into this hole and blow his leg up get
some shrapnel and go home
so the sun goes down and he's loading
his fighting only starts digging man
it's the same thing he digs and he
starts digging and he's digging and he's
digging he's digging through the night
and right as he's finishing up this hole
and he's getting to a point where he can
finally throw this grenade in there and
go home the sun starts to come up
and he's like you know what i got this
but uh
it's a it's a good thing to remember
that when it really sucks the sun's
gonna come up at some point and you'll
start to get warm again push through it
um and it's good lesson learned it's not
easy to dig in frozen ground
took him all night just to dig a hole
big enough for his leg to toss it
it's funny to hear a guy like hackworth
who was you know uh
a very brave person just based on his
action but he was done
he was done it's like deck winners you
know dick winners after everything he
did in world war ii they brought all
they got recalled for korea
he showed up to to the boat they're in
san francisco and they're like hey if
you're a combat vet from world war ii
you don't have to go and he's like cool
i'm out that was dick winters i mean
who's going to question dick winter's
courage but he was like yeah i'm going
back to my farm in pennsylvania um
good luck gentlemen and that was that
um
all right got to go to the book here we
got to get got to get mom back in the
picture here um every time i visited my
real home it was a fight over the marine
corps when i was selected for the
infantry my mom lost it i remember her
yelling the hell you are that's not
[__] happening you'll be used as
cannon fodder she mentioned something
about shooting me in the kneecaps she
swore this was just some macho [__]
because she was a cop she said it wasn't
just me i was dragging down this road i
was forcing her to travel it too
but a young man has to live his own life
and i realized that mine
was the marine infantry so mom was not
stoked on this whole seat
oh it was every time i came home and it
was for the first maybe 10 years uh
and it was
it's like donald rumsfeld dick cheney
george bush oil i'm like mom where's the
detergent like i came home to do my
laundry and you're yelling at me about
donald trump like i don't know anything
about all these kind of things
i want to be a marine infantry i want to
fight and right now i just got to do my
laundry so uh it was it was
always a she was always on a 10 always
yelling about it and then you know
i end up going to a pretty dangerous
place and then it's like okay you're
going to get out and like uh i think i'm
going to stay in
and then like you know my tour comes up
again like okay come back be a fireman
dude
i think i'm going to stay in
um
awesome stuff uh way to listen your mom
from from basic school you get infantry
officer school how long is that course
three months
and
uh you and i were talking earlier about
um
when i had
james webb on the podcast yeah
and he
like gets done with the basic school
gets done with the infrared officer
course goes to vietnam
they like bring him out in the field
point up at a ridge line they go your
platoon's up there
who am i relieving oh it's just a
sergeant you're you're the other platoon
commander was wounded or killed or cass
of act
you got it and he he rolls up there and
the first night he's in combat he's just
calling for fire i mean just get it just
getting after it and really leading a
complex scenario
and i you know i said how
did you feel like you were prepared for
that and he was like yes and
i can only imagine that you going to now
what is it 2007 2008
uh i started that course 2009. okay so
2009.
we got two wars going on um got all
these veterans
teaching you
that must have been
about as squared away as a course could
be
and i would answer
same as secretary webb i would say yes
you know
that course
is an incredible course
and more than anything it prepares you
technically and technically to lead
marines on the very first day it
definitely helps you become mentally and
physically tougher
there's a lot of mental and physical
development that happens uh their moral
development that that happens there and
the instructors as you alluded to were
all iraq guys and so the quality
of the instructor is super selective
there and then just the actual
curriculum there i
you know two of my buddies
our final exercises uh in 29 palms and
they didn't come back with us to
graduate they went to platoons that were
in 29 palms and deployed you know a week
later and so this you know this web part
is still still happening and uh
and you know when i showed up to my
platoon
i know that i have a lot to learn about
leadership i know that i need to listen
to my squad leaders i know all these
things i also know that i could leave
this platoon today and and that is a
great testament to the infantry officers
course are is there one on the east
coast or one on the west coast are they
all it's just in quantico just in
quantico
you just fly out for the final exercise
out to 29 palms okay
go out there and get some um
this is also where in the book you start
talking about um
you start really forming your your bonds
brotherhood now um you got a bunch of
bunch of names bunch of guys you list
off ty anthony alex pearson vince young
cameron west
you got some prior enlisted guys
uh johnny epps am i saying that right
and hey to all the marines who are
butchering your names that's all good
i'm sorry joe patterson
robert kelly
so
this is rob kelly this is the son of
general john kelly
um
john kelly
enlisted in 1970 eventually became a
four-star general you if you recognize
his name it's probably from when he and
you're not in the military it's from
when he when he was the white house
chief of staff
rob was a prior enlisted guy like his
dad fought in fallujah
these are the guys that you're now
forming a bond with and
this is kind of like where you
really start to become a marine
absolutely
yeah it's it's where i
everything up to this point was
hypothetical like i i think this is you
know it all started when i was a
sophomore i said oh i should go do
something about that no idea what that
was and then like oh i navy marine uh
marine guys i like those guys they've
got something and then like oh no one
wants to be infantry i want to be and so
all this stuff is just a theory
and then i get to ioc and it's like no
like these are the people i want to be
around this violent aggressive
stuff that we do here like it speaks to
me in a very and so
you know again grew up with the mom even
though she's a cop she's still this
hippie like there's no like
talks about being a warriors no i
and so it was
i
you know in in reflection there's
there's something about a warrior
calling that was inside my heart and
inside my soul that it finally uh
resonated felt validated when i'm
running through those woods like a wild
animal
uh just attacking and shooting machine
guns and rockets all day with this group
of savage men
and for the first time i said like yes
like you've made the right decision and
this is these are your people this is
your [__]
and uh
and it you know it taught me this many
lessons but one is that you know
it it's all
it's all hard it's all
shitty work it's all tough work but when
you're doing it with the right group of
men like you just talked about like
those are the good times and and you
wouldn't rather be anywhere else and so
um
yeah i i mean that that that list of
names that you just read off all those
guys went on to combat all those guys
went on to do incredible things and then
you know if we get back to november 9th
where we opened with my with my squad
leader i mean that's the day that robert
kelly was killed and
and uh
to have rob kelly as a mentor and a
friend um
you know i didn't know his dad was a
general until he was coming to speak to
us you know that's the kind of guy rob
was that he never would would mention
that um
and just uh i i i hope we maybe i don't
know if we're going to come back to him
but when we found out about the
deployment you know so i'll i'll hold
yeah actually um as soon as i was
reading that section it because you the
way you had it broke out broken down the
book you're like oh we had these guys
they're all just done with either ocs or
rotc and we're all you know went to the
basic school and then it was prior
enlisted guys and you mentioned johnny
epps and joe patterson and robert and i
was like i was like rob kelly son of a
general that's prior enlisted i actually
went and looked that up because it was
amazing right that this guy whose dad is
general was like oh cool what are you
doing i'm enlisting in the marine corps
like hell yeah oh yeah um
i was going to college so i went to
college i had to go to college
uh once i got commissioned did a couple
deployments and then i had to go to
college and i was in college september
11th it happened i'm
and i'm talking to i went to the
university of san diego and i had one of
my professors i was an english major one
of my professors was a nun
and i'm talking to her
and she says like
like don't you know are you going to be
able to stay here longer and i was like
what do you mean she says well don't
don't you want to stay can't you maybe
try and get your masters
i was like what i was what are you
talking about
sister
clay literally i said what do you mean
and she just couldn't comprehend and she
goes well don't you want to stay here
and you know be isn't this like
in her mind this was the greatest thing
ever i'm this guy that was in the navy
and now i'm just gonna have to go to
school
and i was like no i want to go back i'd
go back tomorrow if they would let me
and she says
why do you want to go back she's like
why do you just
dumbfounded why do you why do you want
to go back
and i
in some awkward way because it sounds
bad to say it i was like well i go back
there and i get to be around a bunch of
dudes like me
that we listen to say music we like to
do the same stuff we're interested in
the same thing we laugh at the same
jokes we
we that's where i want to go i want to
get back there and you know for you
showing up there with all these studs
it's like yeah this is this is where i'm
supposed to be
did you have any challenges there was
there anything that you any major
lessons learned if you could go back and
square yourself away
i had the benefit of having a couple
months between when i graduated tbs and
showing up to ioc so you know joe
patterson would would pt us each day and
i'd i'd work out with ty anthony and and
so uh steve tris another so we we i
showed up
in pretty good shape thankfully because
you it's hard to maintain or improve
your fitness at the basis school because
it's just 0 6 to
1900 every day and then you're studying
on the weekends and so thankfully i had
a couple of months and so i
i
the lesson i learned
at
ioc is
is how to embrace the suck
and uh i would say the only thing that i
would say is like it would have been
better if i learned it sooner
um
but i was i was out
we were doing a patrolling exercise at
fort ap hill
and i was just gp holding security
and been days without food uh july and
virginia at ap hill and just ticks and
and i'm holding the security and just
flies landing on my face ants crawling
up my sleeves spiders repelling down
gnats in my ears and on my bellies
grumbling
and i got chaff everywhere and i'm just
trying to fight all this and kind of so
sad and this uh
and just trying to survive moment to
moment and as i continue to kind of
fight nature
i'm on security for that 30 minutes at
this point and and
all the gnats are still there all the
ants are still coming all and i just
finally said like you can't you're not
gonna defeat nature
you just gotta accept it
and in that moment i just stopped
swatting the flies i didn't care that
the ants were crawling up my sleeve
and uh
it allows you to thrive and and when you
when you when you when you
it's it's good you know embrace the
stuck is the marine corps version of
good it's it's the stoics version of a
more fate i love your fate it's it's
this idea that whatever the
circumstances are
i accept them
and i'm going to find
opportunities within this current
environment instead of circumstances
rather than just try to survive in it
and it
it's it gives you power it gives you
agency autonomy you know you no longer
just become this this like this leaf
that's in a and a brook that's getting
tossed around now i have a vote
it may be a lot pretty restrained
options uh based on the the
circumstances but at least i can say
uh how can i best use these challenges
um
and and i think of like somebody like uh
stockdale when when he's when he's in
prison
they say well
was i a victim
no you know you think of uh
schulzenstein when he's in the gulag
archipelago and he says thank you prison
when you think of someone like paul
who
when he's in prison he's rejoicing
i think of sergeant antoni
as he's dying
he
he turns
his last words are is everybody okay
and so it takes all these moments
and it allows you to just uh
to take ownership back and uh and so
yeah i think that is i probably learned
that
two thirds of the way through and i was
probably feeling a little victim uh
throughout most of that curriculum and
then finally i said you know good uh
and now now i'm like crazy because you
know when i'm going up the mountains in
bridgeport i just wish it was colder or
i just wish there was some more snow i'm
so happy that's so hot out here in 29
pounds if it was hotter it'd just be a
little bit better and you know uh but
you you got to say that kind of stuff
and you got to try to at least believe
it otherwise
you're just uh
powerless yeah otherwise everything
really sucks
it sucks when it sucks but
if you can't accept it it's going to
suck a lot
a lot worse um now
this whole book and by the way obviously
i'm only reading highlights get the book
so that you can get the whole story
but it's not just your story it's
about half of it
is written by your interpreter zack and
it's
really interesting to hear his
perspective
because
we as americans
we have a really hard time uh picturing
what
we just picture a stereotype of what we
think in iraq is what we think an afghan
is or whatever we just have this
stereotype in our head and that's kind
of what we blanket over and i i know i
always have to reiterate what an iraqi
person is
when iraqi dad is what an iraqi mom is
what an iraqi family is oh they're a
family actually the way i usually
describe is to say they're like you are
so if you're sitting here listening to
me what's an iraqi family like oh it's a
family there's a dad there's a mom they
want to look out for their kids they're
trying to grow their business they're
trying to get by they're trying to fix
their car they got payments due right
that's what they're doing
and
it's really interesting to hear zach's
story and his perspective he's one of
nine children he's from kunar he's a
pashtun he talks about the pastor wali
which is their
their culture which some people have
heard a little bit about he goes into
some details
hospitality for
visitors right
showing courage that's just the way they
roll you have to show courage in daily
life and you have to show courage and
bravery defending their communities you
gotta show loyalty you gotta show
kindness you gotta show respect
then there's also they have a code for
revenge
they don't tolerate insults they're
expected to take revenge if something
goes against them or at least negotiate
some kind of compensation if something
happens
to their family or to their community um
zach's
mother's father worked for
[Music]
president najibullah who who who they
called dr najeeb who was the president
of afghanistan after the sony soviet
union was driven out so in 1989 the
soviet union leaves um and and this this
guy dr najeeb takes over as a president
and that's where zach's mother's father
worked
zack's father was a soldier
who who worked for the government in
kunar after he got out of the army he
worked as a clerk for the red cross
worked for the red crescent
um
the dr najib's government collapsed in
by 1996
um
the taliban is expanding out a kandahar
province
they eventually capture and execute dr
najeeb they take him and his brother and
hang them from light poles in front of
the presidential palace
that's what's transpiring
during you know as zach is growing up
this is what zach's growing up in
and i'm gonna go to the book here and
again these are this is a section that's
from zach's writing
and he says this i was only five years
old when they came from kandahar
with their long beards
and black makeup surrounding their eyes
to take control of kunar but i knew that
my parents were scared
i remember life was very hard when they
were in power in kunar we pashtuns were
already very conservative but the
taliban declared controls over
everything in our lives each night i
heard father tell my mother about the
new rules imposed by the taliban every
day there were new prohibitions
they have declared television and music
on islamic
then they close the newspaper then women
may no longer work or go to school
father began to grow his beard mother
my mother had to wear a burqa covering
her entire body outside of our home even
her eyes were hidden behind a screen she
was prohibited from looking at strangers
and could not go out of the house
without my father or one of her sons it
was strange to me that i had to escort
my mother
except for the madrasa there were no
schools no university
electricity was scarce maintenance of
roads and buildings stopped
stopped
there was really no access to any of the
basic life needs a government is
supposed to provide
except guns
there were always plenty of guns the
talibs carried ak-47s and rocket
launchers everywhere they went
there was sharia law of course
that was a form of government
the taliban were interested in
they caught off hands cut off the hands
of thieves talibs from the department
for the enforcement of right islamic way
and prevention of evils the religious
police
enforced laws about modesty with sticks
they beat people in public who said they
were not following the laws especially
women
many people were killed by beheading or
stoning as punishment for their
violations there was no real court just
the taliban
although they were from a very different
part of afghanistan and had very
different accents the taliban and
pashtun
like the people in my village
so some of our neighbors were for the
taliban
my father was not and he suffered for
that
power shifts suddenly in afghanistan who
you know and support matters more than
who you are
it has always been that way
my father lost his job because he had
worked under dr najib
he grew his beard even longer so that he
would not attract taliban attention
without his clerk job he became a farmer
in our family any child old enough to
walk was a farmer we grew enough
vegetables to feed ourselves with a
little leftover to sell in the village
market we grew and sold flowers too red
roses afghans love flowers and plant
them everywhere
maybe they represent hope
that something good can grow from dust
i was only 11 years old on september 11
i did not really understand what
happened that day
we really had no concept of america or
the west
we were told that the people there were
infidels and that they would try to make
us stop practicing islam or living in an
islamic way
i certainly did not understand their
governments or laws or the things to
come soon
after the americans began their invasion
i still farmed and played cricket in the
forest but our village was growing more
and more frightened every day
people were scared that the americans
would kill us with their planes
especially those who worked for the
taliban or al-qaeda
my father had the radio up to his ear
all the time
the day the american bombs started
falling across afghanistan the president
of the united states said
the oppressed people of afghanistan will
know the generosity of our america of
america and our allies
as we strike military targets we will
also drop food medicine and supplies to
the starving and suffering men and women
and children of afghanistan
the world had finally remembered we
existed
the americans came with more guns and
more trucks and more planes we hoped
they would bring good things too
afghanistan had nothing
after two decades of war there was no
government we had no schools no police
no military literacy was 18.6 percent in
1979 in 2001 no one knew because no one
had asked
there was nothing to make us a nation
except our hopes
so
i think it's really lucky that zach kind
of got to see
you know he he understood freedom he
understood education and maybe that's
not the best section to read but he
definitely understood freedom he
understood
education he saw the oppressiveness of
the taliban if he would have seen that
he might have
not had this place in his heart where he
wanted to
really help out america um and again uh
almost half the book is his words
so
get the book and we'll read some more
but get the book you want to get the
real details of what it was like on the
ground for these people
that's a great place to get it um
but
september 11th happens america enters
afghanistan
and
for him that's an opportunity he talks
about that's an opportunity for freedom
again like he sees that and eventually
he does end up getting a job as an
interpreter and we'll get there to that
but
going back to you
you get done with
ioc
and you get assigned third battalion
fifth marines three five marines and
anyone that listens to this podcast
knows about
three five marines from
well from with the old breed by eugene
sled
eugene sledge um three five four in
world war one they fought in nicaragua
they fought in world war ii guadalcanal
new britain pelulu okinawa
in korea
they
were at incheon they were at the
breakout withdrawal from the chosen
reservoir in vietnam
they were in away city
they were in the queson valley the death
valley they were in desert shield desert
storm and of course iraq and afghanistan
so you get orders to three five hallowed
unit
um
you get there and you get assigned
um the little quote from the book second
lieutenant schuman first platoon kilo
company
that's what you get told
how does that make you feel
yeah excited i uh i've been reading with
the old breed
and and with eb sledge there and that's
that's kilo 3 5 and uh just
one thing that we as marines do
we do a very good job of preserving our
our history our heritage our legacy it's
it's drilled into you everywhere you go
and then um
so it's it's alive it's a it's a lie
from the the stories that your sergeant
instructors tell you at boot camp and
officer kane at school and and then and
but uh
you know you check in you walk
outside of the 3-5
kilo office and the cp for three five
there's a picture of kilo on palulu with
a note from eb sledge
and like uh
just the this the idea like that you
have
responsibility and an opportunity to
carry that legacy forward i mean it's
it's more it's all you could ever dream
of it's all you could ever hope for
um
second lieutenant schuman first platoon
kilo company
you've been how long have you been in
the marine corps for at this point
a year
nine months so you're nine months to a
year and this is everything you've been
working for through college
and you get this um
but
that being said
there's also like some
and it'll be weird for people to hear
this there's also some bad news and the
bad news is that you're scheduled to go
on a westpac deployment which means
you're gonna be on a ship going around
the pacific ocean
not going into combat that was the plan
for your
battalion
yeah all i want to do is fight i mean
you leave ioc
and
and you
it's just basically this controlled
aggression and this is maximum violence
and uh
and and you and your all your
instructors have just left iraq and and
you know it's what you've been seeing
for the last several years and
uh you're ready to do that you you you
know you've allen iverson you know he
says we're talking about practice we're
talking about practice you want to get
it's time for the game and you want to
go
get
validated
and uh and so when you find out hey
you're going to go to okinawa and float
around a little bit you think well [__]
that's not what i was trying to do here
uh so yeah definitely uh
initially
disappointed i got
i was i guess that disappointment
to it
an extent persisted but once i started
working in leading marines i mean every
day i'm living in san clemente driving
down el camino real past trestles beach
into the north side of camp pendleton to
go shoot machine guns with 35 savages
like it's a pretty good deal and so
pretty quickly like my little sadness
was was mostly taken care of but yeah
still a little disappointed for sure any
challenges when you were doing your work
up preparing for deployment
undoubtedly the the
the start
these so three five last one to iraq and
and so
the senior lance corporals all had um
done the iraq deployment in some of the
sergeants and then then the platoon that
i picked up had just gotten back from
okinawa they were the first
time that 3-5 hadn't been in combat
in 10 years and so they are all feeling
that's what infantry marines joined for
one reason
they joined the fight
and so
they're you know all their seniors have
been to iraq they've all been to combat
they had to live with this that they
didn't
then they of course like
always their their leadership is saying
well we could go we're gonna go we're
gonna go and then they they don't go and
they just you know and so
uh morale was low discipline
very low
uh
there was
i mean it was uh it was
very tough
uh
leadership
is always
challenging and so like i the midshipman
kind of
when i teach in naval academy would kind
of like you know [__] and complain
about different aspects of of leadership
or timing and and i can't think of a
time as a second lieutenant
in the over 245 years in marine corps
where it would be oh this is this must
have been the easy time to be a second
lieutenant it's it's always a tough time
to be
it's in in hue city and caisson i bet it
was pretty hard to be a second
lieutenant you know immediately
following vietnam and the 197 probably
pretty hard to be so there's no time
where it's it's easy and it's it's just
those challenges are different based on
peacetime garrison wartime
but those marines were disgruntled low
morale and not disciplined and uh that's
what i was stepping into uh initially as
a platoon commander
now when we found out we got
we were headed
you better shape up or you can put on
the bench but you did
much of your workout thinking you were
going on westpac right about six months
and um
yeah this is when guys are like well we
gotta do this again we're just gonna go
sit on a boat um
not cool
uh but as you mentioned things things um
changed so you guys get together it's
around christmas time you get together
you gather for your christmas leave a
safety brief where they're gonna tell
you not to be idiots
uh battalion commander has some word to
put out here's what he says
uh here's what you say in the book as we
gathered for our safety brief prior to
releasing marines for christmas leave
lieutenant colonel morris stood in a
circle of more than one thousand marines
all impatient for the freedom of the
leave period and prepared for the usual
tired exhortations about tire pressure
and not drinking and driving those came
in as expected
but when morris announced we would no
longer be deploying to japan the air
became suddenly charged like the ozone
smell before a lightning storm
a thousand marines collectively leaned
in to hear his next words
when he announced that dark horse which
is 3-5 when he announced that dark horse
was instead deploying to the sangan prad
district of helman province afghanistan
there was a roar so loud i felt it as
much as i heard it
i could not have wanted anything more
for christmas i felt a surge of heat
through my body a charge of adrenaline
and excitement and deep down
a tiny cold pit of fear
i looked over at rob kelly expecting to
see the same excitement on his face
and i did not find it i gave him a come
on man look
he looked back at me with half a smile
and said
i was ready for a mew
meaning the japan deployment mine was
the fire of the unblooded
knew sang and meant
we would bury marines
[Applause]
um
yeah
that's what's happening
um
it's hard to explain to civilians
that
the
young men that sign up to go to war
really want to go to war
and it's hardly
hard to um
convince
young men that are really excited to go
to war
to be careful what you wish for
at this point um we haven't really
talked about this yet but you have
long time girlfriend at this point
andrea is that right andrea andre andrea
andrea so you got andrea how long have
you have you been together with her at
this point
uh close to 10 years
and you so you met in high school yep
and
um so this is a lot i mean you don't get
more much more long term in a
relationship as a 20 whatever old your
guy you are at the time than 10 years
that's that's a long time
and um
you weren't a perfect boyfriend no
but you'd still been together for a long
time
and you decide that you're going to
break up with her just before deployment
yeah i couldn't get my [__] together
i i knew it was the right thing to do
she's my high school sweetheart you know
we met at youth group
[Music]
she'd always been good and loyal
and uh devoted
and she's beautiful and uh
she's everything i could ever hope or or
dream of and um
the right thing to do for a girl that's
been dealing with your crap for you know
10 years at that point a decade by the
way is to make an honest woman of her
you know and uh
so we go ring shopping
um
this is all pre-deployment leave we go
ring shopping we're talking about it and
uh and i don't have the courage to to do
the right thing and uh
so we pull up to lax
we're about to deploy the next day and
she's about to fly back to chicago and
um
she thinks i'm about to ask her to marry
me and instead i say uh
you should
you should find a new boyfriend while
i'm gone and she just uh
she had a you know
she had a fountain drink in the cup
holder
gave me a little fountain drink bath and
uh
told me what i thought i was real
[__] and
that was it and um
yeah uh terrible terrible thing i did
there and
um
you
all right you get done with that you
spend the last day um back in
back in california
you go over you go with cam who's one of
your buddies
and you go with rob you go to general
kelly's house
and you have a barbecue um
it's like
a pretty poetic scenario for for you
guys to be rolling out it's gotta be
kind of crazy going to general kelly's
house for like the going away right
so there's the cabins on pelton and we
went down to the del mar uh beach and
those cabins there and
cam and i had after the little fiasco
with andrea we got hammer drunk and uh
like the next morning it's like the day
we're gonna get in the buses that night
but rob says hey
you know stop by
have some lunch and uh
like
it's got the shake still from from and
uh general kelly you know they like to
drink pvr and like
have a beer tom i'm like well
well you're gonna say you say yes sir
and so uh yeah i mean it was i mean
it's always when you're a second
lieutenant you're around a four-star
general it's uh there's there's it's a
little bit
weird uh but
really
uh despite the hangover what was really
uh
captured my attention is just this the
over the overall family dynamic of just
a family really
centered around
service and and duty and then just the
love
and how so much of that love was
through rob and emanated from rob and um
and just as a guy who'd
never had that
it just uh was always remarkable just to
kind of to see that
from there um
it's go time
going to the book
from the battalion headquarters at ford
operating base jackson 35 was
responsible for almost 37 square miles
of sengan district and almost 60 000
people living throughout
i was in afghanistan a week and at pb
fires for 24 hours when i received my
first mission on october 9th 2010. i had
everything i thought i wanted now it was
time to find out the truth i left patrol
base fires with a mix of 96 marines and
afghan national army soldiers to look
out three areas the three five
headquarters wanted to know more about
in addition to first platoon i had a
host of attachments four marines from
three seven to give us their insight
into the area and their experience
within it
an entire squad of engineers and two
explosive ordnance disposal marines to
contend with ieds the primary threat in
sangin a section of six snipers the
embedded training team detailed to work
with the ana
three interpreters to help us
communicate a joint terminal attack
controller to get us air support if any
of the taliban who typically operated in
groups of three to four men wanted to
challenge a group of 96.
sangin was prom was primarily dirt and
blowing dust
but irrigation canals stretching out
from the banks of the helmet river
created verdant fields of corn and the
pink and red splashes of opium poppy
on trails roads anywhere we would be
forced to pass the taliban hid the
taliban hid ieds by the hundreds
they buried yellow plastic jugs
containing pounds of homemade explosives
triggered by pressure plates that
completed a circuit when someone stepped
on them ieds were indiscriminate weapons
killing marines and afghan civilians
alike their density demanded we move
single file
with about 30 feet between each person
to keep an ied from getting more than
two or three of us at once
patrol base fires was at the center of
it all
walking single file is the best way to
mitigate an ied threat but is a horrible
way to encounter your first ambush i was
at the front of the formation moving
among the jade leaves and whispers of
wind through a cornfield stalks towering
over us all and concealing our movement
when machine gun rounds from a nearby
building began ripping through the corn
i dove behind a brush pile that
concealed me from view but would not
stop a bullet much less hundreds of them
the size of our group and the dispersed
formation meant our element was in a
firefight before the remainder of my
patrol completely exited from pb fires
i was going to die before i got the
second half of my unit out of the base
i looked to my left at one of my marines
sergeant joseph nickirk netkirk nikirk
nykirk
and shouted i'm gonna stand up and put
some suppressive fire through that
window you fire grenade through it
i stood and fired at the window as
quickly as i could while still retaining
any kind of accuracy nyquirk followed
with a grenade that silenced the machine
gun we both dropped into the back into
the corn where the 37 lieutenant acting
as our tour guide turned to me and said
sarcastically lieutenant schuman you got
your combat action ribbon now make a
decision
i was angry he was a fellow lieutenant
not some not an ioc instructor
i was the new guy so i just stayed quiet
and took it but i did think to myself
make a decision i did make a decision my
decision was not to die in the impact
zone of a machine gun and kill the guy
shooting at us
i thought i wanted combat but finding
myself in a complex ambush with half the
platoon still in the patrol base seemed
like a bad way to start suddenly the
combat action ribbon seemed less
important less than an hour later i
knelt at the edge of a cornfield as the
ana their american advisors and the
three interpreters spoke to a local
elder to tell him we would need to use
his compound for 24 hours like most in
helmand it was a mini fortress made of
thick walls six to ten feet high with a
sh sheet steel gate goats and children
would almost certainly roam within while
women in burkas stayed out of sight
inside homes made of the same
mud brick as the walls
as i waited for an update from the
compound a single shot rang out
followed by sergeant decker coming at me
in a run
sir teague is a teague
sir teague shot someone i took a breath
okay did he have a gun decker nodded his
head yes sir
is he dead very all right well tell
teague he did a good job
that's when the reality of saying hit me
we could kill people here
it was a notion that would soon become
prosaic but in the moment
it was striking
so that's the kick off to deployment
right there
right into it right into it i've i
always say that i got very lucky in my
combat experience that
it was the most gradual nice um
escalation over time sure and that's
just that's just pure luck
and you did not get that gradual
escalation baptism by fire
[Laughter]
i had a guy that was one of the sante
raiders on
uh special forces guy
he did one mission in vietnam
he they flew from america he was a brand
new special forces guy
he his first combat operation was sante
raid he got off the aircraft and five
seconds later was killing a dude like
stepped off the aircraft and killed
someone and 20 minutes later they were
gone and that was his whole experience
in vietnam but it was a pretty intense
20 minutes
um
that's the kickoff to this deployment
and this deployment is an extremely
kinetic deployment for you guys um and
you know this is true of all wars i mean
depending on where you are and when
you're there
it can be anything from a deployment
where you're sitting around a chow hall
eating whatever gourmet food from some
contractor
or it can be this this type of
deployment
this is a this is a hardcore deployment
how how much did you know when you were
going in
how hot was it when you were showing up
there you you knew what you were getting
into
not really
we were still very coin centric
so you know the the final exercise that
uh that a battalion does before they
um
go out to deployments called emv or
enhanced mojave viper now it's got a new
name of course but uh
like that final exercise that we're
doing was all about
kissing babies uh there's a big
key leader engagement where you're
sitting with the village elder and
shaking hands with him and so it was
like
shuras and kaley's and
my when i ran training we had
we started doing key leader engagements
right and
they were going to go bad 100 of the
time yeah it was so awesome like but we
had great actors and people would come
out being the key leader guy and you
know it's very nice to meet you and the
spider hole would open up and out come
people machine guns but it sounds like
maybe you weren't getting that treat you
were getting the treatment like it was
going to go like hey that's what you're
there to do so we still did our our live
fire training uh but the emphasis was
you know the
to try to recreate the iraq awakening
you know that that was that was the
playbook and uh
about a week before we left though the
company commander of the ao that we were
gonna rip out
um he's now battalion commander ryan
cohen lieutenant colonel cohen came and
he'd been medevaced
and he's like
[__] is real and this was the first guy
that kind of say like hey you you're
gonna go over there and
fight where did you guys know you were
going where you were going specifically
we did but
the intel briefs
were pretty spotty the ars there's there
there's not a whole lot of are you
communicating with guys directly
so i i think some guys have sipper maybe
talking but you know second lieutenant
no not getting read in on really much of
this stuff and still
i mean to the point that the book that
i'm reading on the flight over is three
cups of tea
and uh
that's an appropriate reaction and then
uh you know we're doing the the the
cultural courses at leatherneck the big
base before we fly into out to the
patrol bases and i've got like a a
little smart pack of like how are you
how do you do nice to meet you sir and
i'm i'm quizzing all my squad leaders
and i'm like no you don't know how to
say nice to meet you like let's do it
again and like that's still
really what i thought we were we're
headed into and um it very immediately
uh was apparent that no one was gonna
drink tea and everybody was gonna try to
kill us
we when um
in ramadi we had guys like our friends
were coming to relieve us
and so we're telling them
um what's going down and what's
happening and and
they're going to
like my guys are coming on wounded
they're going to my guys funerals here
it was like a
it was a rare occasion for you know that
tight turnover
into like really hard combat but you
know they came over they they knew what
they were getting into doesn't a lot of
times it doesn't doesn't work like that
three cups of tea
i had uh one of my
uh senior leaders
who's a friend of mine and but you know
he was really hyped on three cups of tea
and we were not
especially coming home from ramadi we
were especially not hyped about three
cups of tea
and
when that book turned out to be a big
lie
boy did i have fun with that one
throwing it back in his face
um
did you when you um
during like those final exercises and
stuff
what was the attitude with your guys
were they like okay well that's what you
know that's what the boss is saying
we're gonna be doing we're gonna be
drinking tea with the locals no one had
nef afghanistan experience and and so
you know
some of those guys had been in the
flusion 08 where it was kind of
that
you know clear hole build it was really
more towards the build phase there and
so
that 08 iraq experience was kind of
reinforced some of the stuff that we're
doing and so
you know we're all
hoping for a fight but we're marines and
we're going to do whatever we're told we
got to do and do it well and so if if
it's kissing babies and you know and
then we'll we'll do that you know and
that's kind of what we're
so what was the
what was the mission
that you guys were tasked to do like
broadly
yeah secure
provide security for the same in
district ao increase security that i
mean increase security
that's it and your company commander
was when you write about him in the book
he had an aggressive attitude
he did um
but it's it was hard to know like what
his tolerance or willingness of risk
assessment or or you know risk tolerance
was or what he would accept or what he
what he wouldn't but
he was
we kilo companies sledgehammer eb sledge
have historically always had
the aggressive reputation and we had
hardcore sergeants that work up and and
and yeah so we maintained this
uh which it was enabled by our rco is
this really aggressive company for sure
and and then in order to maintain
or establish security
you're going out on patrols yeah you're
taking a a with you all the time
uh trying not to
initially we would often forget him at
the at the patrol base um
but towards the latter half of the
deployment we were bringing them always
bringing them out but we we
that first mission had like such high
visibility because it was a but we were
securing battalion objectives and doing
a three-day operation that we had to
have dna with us um
but
they a were happy to not go out and we
were happy to not take them out and so
uh
it wasn't towards the latter half the
deployment that we really started kind
of employing them consistently
um
yeah those those first patrols
were
conventional
fighting i mean it was the enemy was in
a defensive depth with obstacles covered
by machine guns
and we were on the offense and just
straight assaulting into an enemy
defense and and that's
and so anything about
improving local security or doing any
kind of counterinsurgency it was no just
go out there and kill as many guys as
you can
yeah well that's actually part of
counter insurgency is killing a bunch of
bad guys and that was uh that's a very
effective and necessary part of it
because you can't build schools while
you're getting blown up and you know
security for the populace is the way
that i
for lack of a better word pitched it up
my chain of command what we were doing
hey we're going to provide security for
the populace well how are you going to
do that we're going to kill all these
bad guys or at least as many of them as
we can
um what was your
op tempo like so how often are you guys
going out how long you staying out for
i mean every day i mean we're we're
doing platoon sized patrols every day
for the first month or two and that's
because
you needed a platoon
sized element to get in the to
effectively fight the types of fights
that were engaged in and then then and
then it was a squad and but it was
tough because you had you had a squad on
post
you had a squad on qrf and then you had
a squad patrolling and the qrf squad
almost always got called out and so
that rest squad was really never resting
and so you're either on post
patrolling or responding out as qrf so
it was it was uh that tempo was uh
pretty brutal and and so the troops were
out every day
i don't know if it's the right word but
it sounds like it might be the right
word you kind of got in a little bit of
trouble
up the chain of command yeah um
you got counseled for your cowboy
attitude and this kind of thing break
that down a little bit what mistakes did
you make what could you have done to
better
where were you right where were you
wrong
we were out on operation and uh we've
been out until two or three and and i
and i
called into the main the cp and i said
hey we're gonna we're gonna turn our
radio off for a couple hours conserve
battery will be up at zero six and calm
with the radio check
and when i turned the radio back on at
zero six couple hours later it was like
broken arrow where are you sledgehammer
or have you been overrun like sledge
number one call in i'm like
hey
we called you guys got rogered up that
that we were turning the radio off
and the night watcho
said that was good to go uh so it's like
no you're not in the log book i'm like
uh
so
yeah when we got back you know my my co
was there and he said you know i'm gonna
kick your ass and you think you don't
have to call in and you don't think you
don't have to report and
one of my squad leaders uh we were in a
fight and uh they had shot some artie or
jaimar and
the maine kept calling for a sit rep and
you know what's the bda what's the sit
rep and he said how about you guys just
grab a cup of coffee take a seat i'm in
a fight
and uh
you know we had uh this company gunny
carlisle he was a savage dude and he's
like what'd you say you [__]
like they're fighting over the radio
and so my guys were yeah my guys were uh
um
it's like kind of that common tension
between higher headquarters and the
dudes doing the fighting and
uh
so yeah we got reigned in and and uh we
got but
you know it was punishment that had to
go back to the company position
from being out at a patrol base just as
the platoon by ourselves
but
it wouldn't turned out it was a reward
because the
area around the company hadn't been
patrolled aggressively and we had been
patrolling now for a month a month and a
half so we kind of created a little
security bubble we were having a harder
time getting in fights and so they
brought us back and then the first time
we go out we killed a ton of dudes and
come back with some ak-47s we're like
yeah sledgehammer one's here now you
know here's his aks uh
and so
yeah i i could have had more tact
for sure um
yeah i was probably i was probably light
on tact yeah um
one thing i used to tell my guys was
that like the next the next echelon is
always messed up right from our
perspective then that's excellent up the
chain of command is always like they
don't understand well here's the deal
why don't they understand they don't
understand because i'm not doing a good
job of pushing them information and i'm
not seeing what their perspective is
because they're probably got someone
screaming at them going what do you mean
you're dropping already into that tell
us what's going on and they're asking
and that's how these things that's how
you get a little disconnect you get a
disconnect between the guys that are
fighting and the guys that are not there
there there can be some animosity there
and it can be a problem if you're not
careful especially from a leadership
position you know for you for you guys
that are out there
you're going to be the one that
translates things up and down the chain
of command
and that that that is not an easy job
but it's a really important job because
if we have a real disconnect then we're
not getting the support that we need and
it causes all kinds of problems so
don't take anything personally
right when they're asking you what the
hell is going on
just do your best to try and tell them
what the hell is going on when they're
asking you
stupid questions
it's because you didn't tell them what
you know how you were going to do a
kazzavac in this particular scenario or
what you how you were going to handle
this particular type of threat they're
asking you this stuff because they want
to know because you didn't tell them and
just do your best i know it's hard
and for senior leaders out there
when your folks are in the field
they're working on some [__]
and as soon as they get the chance
they're going to tell you what's up but
leave them alone as long as you possibly
can leave them alone and let them sort
their [__] out
and then they'll get back to you and you
can you can get your numbers and get
your update and get your sitrep and all
that
just try and understand each other's
perspectives please it goes a long way
yeah i think that was a good summation
of lessons learned
um
all this fighting going on um it's gonna
there's gonna be a price
cam your buddy cam gets severely wounded
by an ied
lost his right leg in um a lot like
injured his left leg
or sorry lost one leg it really injured
the other one um right eyes messed up
that that seemed at least when i read it
in the book it seemed like that was a
little bit of a reality check for you
because we are young and we feel like
invincible
yeah cam was this kind of larger than
life john wayne kind of figured to me a
guy big strong dude that we all looked
up to charismatic and uh
and when i came in the patrol base that
day you know will donnelly the second
platoon commander meets me and says i
don't think cam's gonna make it
and we were taking casualties at such a
crazy rate
and i'm like man if cam can go down i
mean
like um
and i hadn't i was good in a fire fight
i could still kind of compartmentalize
and focus on the thing that i needed to
focus on in that moment to to make the
right decisions
uh
but i was
i
there's there's another great scene and
gates of fire where uh the spartans
before battle will will break the twigs
and and they'll put half the twig in the
basket it's it's like uh some symbolic
of a of a dog tag and so that if they
get so disfigured they match up the
twigs at the end of the battle and they
say okay this is this guy but there's
another aspect of that is it's they
break off their humanity because they're
they're
their sons their dads their husbands and
they're about to go have to stick a
sipho sword into somebody's guts and so
they've got to separate
and i still had not separated
my humanity
from the violent warrior
killing and death that i was so
intimately that was the world that i was
living and i think of like if you think
of it like it's like the river sticks
you know we'd cross the river sticks and
we're living in hades and i kind of had
one foot on one shore and one foot in in
hell and i was kind of just and um
and when i when i found out when i heard
cam wasn't gonna make it
he did ultimately make it but when i
found that out i just uh
i broke down and then i i went back to
my room
and i had stored away a little uh
snickers bar at the bottom of my rook
and i thought on a rainy day you will
need this for your morale and uh i
didn't think that rainy day was gonna be
like a week and a half into the
deployment but i go to digging my ruck
and i and i find that uh these little
taliban mice
have been living and [__] in my ruck
and they ate my snickers bar
and i had i had no more resilience left
you know and so that was like the and so
uh
i got sick i was puking emotional not in
front of my troops this was all you know
private but uh
it was at that point that i said you
can't be feeling these
things anymore like you have a job and
so
you separate
from you detach from that humanity
and everything is compartmentalized from
that moment forward which makes you
super effective under fire
the issue is if you don't reconnect to
that humanity after your deployment
uh you become
cold
emotionally unavailable
you don't experience the richness and
fullness of life
it's a really safe way to live very
compartmentalized because i don't get
too happy i don't get too sad
uh but it's not a very
fulfilling way to live and and
and the longer you and you know i was
right back in afghanistan 12 months
later and so the longer you kind of
keep all those nerve endings dead so
that you don't can't feel anything
longer it's harder to turn them back on
and uh
and also you you start to get afraid of
like
what will i feel when i do turn all that
stuff back on because i've been packing
stuff in the sea back for a long time
here
and so what i convinced myself is
is that like hey you don't have time you
got troops to lead you got stuff to do
like you don't have
and what really what i found is like i
didn't have the courage
to turn it back on i didn't have the
courage to feel the things that i needed
to feel to figure out what the hell was
going on
and i
basically told myself a lie they said
you're too busy or too busy but really i
was too scared to unpack that sea bag
and
as i said good way to be in combat
probably bad way to live
well i think it's important to
a lot of times things are going on
around us and we just don't know that
they're happening so like you pointing
that out
it will help someone else go oh i know
what's going on like i
i know um my wife i was on deployment my
wife sent me a email this is before
facetime and stuff like this but she
sent me an email and said um the kids
want to see a picture of where you sleep
like can you send a picture of where you
sleep
and
yep got it and i i remember i took a
picture of you know like my little
wooden
plywood cot thing and i looked at it and
i was like oh this isn't good and i
pulled out you know from some
dug down in some backpack
grabbed some pictures of my wife and
kids hung them up around the bed
took a picture
took them back down put them back in the
folder and back in the rucksack because
the last thing i needed to be doing was
thinking about my wife and kids when i
got guys that are you know counting on
me to make decisions
um
and i think that that was like a
physical representation
that i knew what i was doing
and i think that when i got home i kind
of knew okay you can put these pictures
back up now in your head and i think a
lot of times like just you the way
you're describing that other people
will
recognize
that oh they took those pictures down
they put them in a folder they're not
looking at them when you get done with
that deployment you can open that folder
back up and it's going to be okay
uh important stuff to learn
um
at this point uh you meet zach for the
first time
seemed like you guys kicked it off
pretty good hit it off pretty good out
of the gate
yeah initially very transactional he was
a good interpreter uh he knew his
pasture he knew english up to that point
the only interpreters who were left
either didn't speak english or didn't
speak the local dialect and so they knew
they weren't going to be able to get a
job so they hung around and and what
what i was finding is that every
interpreter was
quitting
uh or
they were such a liability under fire
that we'd have bounded a couple hundred
meters like
where's the terp and we gotta go
and uh and so we had had a rough rough
uh go with our interpreter so yeah he
shows up he's fit he's healthy
he's not a coward and yeah that's good
meanwhile you're pushing going to the
book here
in our first nine days of operations
first platoon killed 15 taliban we were
fighting harder and killing more enemy
than any unit in 3-5 by extension that
meant we were fighting and killing more
than any unit in afghanistan
i saw that as in keeping with my ceo's
direction as i understood it
but pushing that hard can create
political and personal issues that
people more removed from the sharp end
of things can perceive as unnecessary
risk
they may even be right given the clarity
that distance can offer
in my aggressive approach to the area of
operations i followed the rules of
engagement but i was not particularly
attuned to political liability that
increased the farther anyone got from pb
fires
but i was consciously absorbing a lot of
physical risk
it made me short of patience with people
i saw as less engaged which to be honest
was everyone who was in afghanistan and
not in first platoon
when i got back to pb fires that day the
ceo told me he was pulling first platoon
back to fob increment over his concerns
that i required closer supervision
we were moving but thankfully
zach was coming with us
um
we kind of we kind of
addressed that the fact that that little
disconnect showed up
um
between you
and this is like i mean how many books
can you read movies can you watch about
that disconnect
between
the ramps the rear echelon [__]
and the people on the front line um
there's a lot of documentation
about that
uh
you you just um you get back to fob
increment like you said and um
the ops continue
the ops are still going on back to the
book
that command is a lone is lonely is a
trite observation but it is no less true
for the countless times it's been
observed it should be paired with the
fact that leadership hurts every time
you discipline a marine that you love
every time you watch them bleed every
time you watch them breathe their last
it hurts
i was 24 years old and living a reality
that i now look back upon and wonder if
some of it even truly happened
i want to deny that humans could be so
callous as i became in the destruction
of people put on this earth by the same
god i was
i was convinced i would not survive
sangin but i had realized that life is a
gift and if i did survive i had some
growing up to do
i prayed to god and asked that if i did
survive he would help me live a grateful
meaningful life that would do honor to
the people denied that chance it was
learned i was largely incapable of
making any objective decisions myself
beyond where to patrol next and how to
fight through the next ambush but i was
ready to acknowledge
i was not the man i professed to be
i called andrea and told her i wanted to
be a better man that i could
only do that with her behi
beside me
i apologize for mistreating the woman
who loved me and begged her to take me
back
she agreed
though i still thought it unlikely i
would ever live to see her again
the idea
was something to live for
at some point that evening the ceo came
in and told me that my friend and mentor
lieutenant robert kelly was dead
struck and killed instantly by an ied
earlier that day
i rolled over and stared at the wall
i thought about rob
cam west and me spending the last day
before he deployed drinking beer del mar
with robert and his family
the next day was the 245th birthday of
the united states marine corps
first platoon killed four taliban
it didn't bring anyone back
[Music]
by thanksgiving 2010 most of my closest
friends in 3-5 rob kelly cameron west
will donnelly and gunnery sergeant
carlisle had been killed or wounded
only staff sergeant henley and
lieutenant vic garcia who replaced cam
at pb fires with third platoon remained
i only saw vic in passing
another ioc classmate james byler had
been horribly wounded losing both his
legs
the death or grievous injury of friends
with whom i had been living training and
fighting for two years left me feeling
dead inside
i was just waiting for my body to catch
up
we had arrived in sangin
in october 2010 and settled into a life
of brutal sameness we patrolled through
suffocating heat and penetrating cold
sometimes multiple hours long patrols in
a day we engaged the elders we did post
blast analysis we responded to ambushes
we called in medevacs we called in air
support we zipped our friends into bags
for a final ride home
they were men i loved because i knew
them or i loved despite not knowing them
for the simple fact that they had
volunteered to serve as marine infantry
men in a time when that meant war
but it was harder and harder to feel
that emotion as the toll of dead and
wounded grew and i felt increasingly
ground
under the wheels of war
so this is the
burden of command
that you're talking about
and
as you mentioned it's a burden that
leaders have to bear
alone
um and what's interesting and it's an
interesting i mean this is what the book
is about
is that you actually had an outlet
for
this
and that outlet
ended up being
your interpreter zack
he wasn't a marine
he was there was no um
there was no mask to put on with zach
how did that relationship grow and
develop
out of necessity for my
sanity is kind of how it
came to be in um
you know this this idea that
war is both heaven and hell and that
each each day
you're experiencing
the worst
depravity that you can imagine but then
you're seeing you know no greater love
that has a man who laid down his life
for his friends you're seeing the
greatest forms of love manifested
where someone
willingly lays down their life for their
friends so you
you get these little glimpses of heaven
and hell
and through that you know you start to
grow and mature
and and you know general uh general
mattis kind of talks about as he got his
phd in combat you know that that you
learn so much about life um
in in five minutes in a fire fight that
maybe could take five years outside of
it and so
i'm refining my character
i'm growing up finally i saw a little
boy i went to combat a little boy and i
finally start to say it's time for you
to be a man
and you
none of this is guaranteed
and if you do make it what are you going
to do differently because
what you profess is not
congruent with your actions and so
first time i get the sat phone like call
andrea a little cry and a little sad you
know i know i broke up with you please
forgive me
take me back
um
and then uh
yeah i i it's
you kind of hinted at this idea that
that as the junior officer you are the
damn you you you're the between two
rushing tides you know higher and then
and then your troops and your
subordinates and so you are
in the middle of this and so you're
trying to
keep all the crap from rolling downhill
on them but at the same time you got all
this stuff bubbling up because you got a
bunch of 18 year old kids that got stuff
going on in their lives that are losing
their own friends and it's all valid
it's all valid it's almost all valid i
should say and it's and it's you who's
the mediator of of all this higher the
pressure from higher and the bubbling up
from from your supporters plus you've
got some stuff going on your own life
like you're trying to get back with your
girlfriend like your best friends get
getting killed or injured right so like
you've got your own and and you've got
to be like this this
person this intermediary right in
between all that and the pressure just
you just keep absorbing pressure
uh because you don't want to pass it to
your troops
and you can't pass it to higher
and so uh an outlet
uh was critical and and because you
can't like my platoon sergeant had been
through enough like i couldn't
he was dealing with all the same crap
and so i didn't want to put anything
else on his plate
and uh there was really only one
person who i could vent to and that
would and that was zach and uh
yeah it was uh it really would help me
maintain my sanity
um
so
this book again i'm reading ten less
than ten percent of reading four percent
of this book um you have a ton of
experiences here that you talk about i'm
trying to get some of the high points um
you develop this awesome relationship
with zach who's a good listener and
and who you can talk to about what's
going on
um fast forward a little bit
of actually fast forward quite a bit
there's a this is a was this a seven
month deployment yes so it's a seven
month deployment i think we covered
maybe one or two operations
i'm going to go all the way um
forward to
i think it was your last stop or
certainly one of your last stops this is
the a turnover operation which is always
a
which is always sketchy anyways because
you got a bunch of people that are
coming in they have their ideas you have
your ideas and if that's not a good if
they're not open to your ideas it's
going to be it's going to be a lot
harder
um there's an
area outside the wire
that's called the golf course
and when you guys go on patrol you stay
away from the golf course because it's
filled with ids you guys go out on
patrol when you leave to go out on
patrol you guys are going through the
village where there's a bunch of afghans
running around so you can't put a bunch
of pressure plate ieds so it's a lot
less ieds
new lieutenant so
on this op is it mostly your guys or is
it mostly his guys no it's this the last
of the left seat right seat so they're
it's just me and two sergeants and all
his guys and it's all his guys he wants
to go out patrol through the golf course
you
strongly recommend that that's not a
great idea
he decides that
it is a good idea and he's going to go
out
i'm going to go out going to take the
patrol to the golf course
guy hits a low order ied out of the gate
um what happens then
so sergeant nikirk was one of my one of
my three marines that was or one of my
two other marines that were on that
patrol
he i see him go up in the yellow smoke
and i
think you know son of a [__] and when i
get up to him
he's uh
standing on top of a 105 shell with a
with one a yellow jug underneath and the
yellow jug just is barely cracked open
and uh we're we're only 100 meters
outside the patrol base at this point so
we call eod to come from the company
position they come out and they say 105
shell on a 40 pound jug would have
killed you know a couple people in front
couple people in back
you know nikirk you would
be in little pieces uh
and they said this is actually a
tripwire id this is the first time we've
seen this in this ao we've never seen
this uh little fish line that you you
kick in the so two little branches
and you kick the little
fish wire you can't see it and that's
what close the circuit rather than a
pressure plate
and uh
and so they reduced the ied
nikirk has hme the homemade explosives
all over his face he's been doused in it
he's uh jittery and he's like uh can i
go back with eod back to the
cp and i'm like yeah go ahead
uh and decker my third squad leader
turns to me and says like can i go back
with them too because
these guys they're going to get us
killed
and i just had a son on this deployment
and i haven't met my son yet
he named his son maximum danger decker
by the way
and absolute kind of guy he is
he's still in
uh one of my heroes and and uh i'm like
hey decker like if if stuff goes
sideways out here i need at least one
other person i know that i can rely on
like sorry you gotta stay
[Music]
and he's not happy about it but roger
and you still couldn't convince the new
lieutenant like hey bro remember when i
said this was a bad idea
we just got the absolute
luckiest
thing we could have ever hoped for yeah
let's backtrack and try this again
tomorrow
correct couldn't talk him off uh
crossing the field but i was able to do
is convince him that hey send the
engineer who's already on the far side
to sweep back through the field because
he's clearly missed at least one ied
uh that should have had a pretty big
signature coming off a 105 shell so
he's gonna re-sweep if we're gonna push
through this field and as that guy
starts to sweep back
goes up
and uh immediately
huge ambush i mean just firing from
everywhere
and
this is this unit's first time in
contact so they're you know just heads
down just not looking where they're
firing just you know blossom shooting
everywhere
and there's only one marine who's
standing up running into the field to go
get the guy who got this bone up and
it's sergeant decker the guy who just
said a few minutes before hey sir can i
go back because i've never met my son
and i'm like okay well now he's going to
be dead and the last thing i'm going to
live with forever is that
this this kid will never meet his dad
because uh and so i
i'm able to flag him down i'm like
you're not going to go i'm going to go
but just getting across the canal
towards the field i mean that the canal
looked like it was like a hail storm
with just the bullets ripping through
the water hitting all the sides of the
dirt and so just
it was uh and so i'm running along the
line i'm like where's the corman where's
the corman where's it corman uh finally
one little hand goes up i'm like
grabbing by the troop stab i'm like
you're following me i'm like decker you
calling the medevac
i'll go out there and get this guy
and i'm the only guy standing up
and uh so the the machine gun the pcam
is just following me through this field
and as i enter into this field i'm like
uh
105 shell on top of a 40 pound jog like
the kids told us that that they said
they saw them at least put 15 to 20 ids
in this field
uh we were on a big op we had just left
like a skeleton security it was in it
was uh and this place was in like uh low
ground we couldn't see it
and so the taliban puts at least 15 to
20 ids in there we've been in this field
for five minutes and hit two of them
so i'm going in this field thinking
uh
best case scenario no legs
ml cola most likely course of action
here you you are dead and then a lot of
pieces people are picking you up with a
vacuum you know um
and i'm also like the pka pkm is just
following me the whole way through you
know i'm a tall guy with a big head and
it's like yeah that's an easy target uh
shoot that thing
and uh and every time i put my foot down
i'm like mother [__] you know like uh
and we get to the casualty
start the treatment on the casualty uh
he's got
it lowered dead it again but it it
heaved him up and slammed him down and
he his hit a compound fracture his arm
bone was sticking through and so i'm
like okay that's good that's not a big
deal doc you got that
and i've been carrying the m32 for a
couple weeks and uh it's a six six
shooter grenade launchers like a
revolver that shoots grenades
and i'm like yeah get something and uh
so i got to pop some nugs you know
six-piece nug nope 12-piece nug how many
nugs do you need before you quiet down
and you know we i'm able to get these
guys to
you know
break contact
and uh
but now i'm thinking like okay now i
gotta walk back with this guy because
when i'm running out
i'm thinking i'm gonna get shot i'm
thinking i gotta go help this marine oh
i don't even know this marine right he's
from the different unit but he's a
marine so it doesn't matter so like i'm
at that point
i am thinking with every step like a
little pucker factor for sure but
there's a lot compelling me forward like
not getting shot and trying to get to
this guy
and now i'm like okay well now we gotta
walk back
and this is the engineer
uh so he's the guy that sweeps the
ground and so uh
yeah it was a
it was a the taliban
did not treat me nice on my way out
that's for sure
um
you get back you get the wounded guy
back to the line um you look at the the
lieutenant you say this patrol's over
at which point he admits uh i i guess i
should have listened to you about the
route
it's that's the thing about combat it's
so um
unique is that
everybody can live the same experience
but have a different version of it
and so like this guy's a super talented
guy way smarter than me he had done he
did great stuff with that platoon so i
have nothing but great stuff to say
about him
he remembers it some of the these
details differently so i will i will put
it put that out there
i remember this
clear as day to me from my perspective
is this how it happened uh but yeah we
agreed patrol's over
uh he said yeah that was me going
through the golf course wasn't the right
call i said yeah i think so
and when i smoked my first cigarette did
you talk to him while you were writing
this
uh
i posted something about it one day
again not indicting him not calling him
out but just kind of talking about
talking through this patrol
and he you know he had sent me a message
he's like well you know what here's what
how i saw that all kind of unfold and
and again there's no uh there's no
animosity there's a ton of mutual
respect
nobody knows
well besides vic garcia i think who is
the my adjacent platoon commander out
there out there in the northern green
zone like nobody else can
empathize
with
what we were doing on the edge of the
empire and the most kinetic area of
operations more than this guy so like
there's a lot of mutual respect but um
yeah we had our difference of opinion
there
you smoked your first cigarette after
this operation
you said uh and
that's it right for this deployment yeah
um
you
leave zach you talk about the fact you
talk about what that's like when um
when you know you're leaving zach
basically on the tarmac um you had this
great relationship with him
uh he ends up getting a job another
translating job he ends up leaving that
ao as well uh but we'll we'll get into
some of that
but it's you
at this juncture returning home
i'm gonna go to the book
on april 20th 2011 i landed back on u.s
soil
i was 25 years old and had just lived a
lifetime on fast forward
my body was battered and my brain was
traumatized by multiple blasts the type
of injuries sustained by so many of us
in the post-9 11 wars
but i also came home from sangin
exhausted embittered
angry and unsure how to express any of
it
there was no way to physically represent
the moral injuries i had sustained and i
did not know a way to talk about them
though they were evident to anyone who
knew me
i was still angry at what i had felt
been what i felt had been kilo company
headquarters punishing me for
aggressively implementing orders i was
given
i was depressed by the death and injury
of my friends
i was physically wrung out from seven
months of insomnia
long daily movements under load
and the accumulated stress of leading
young men in a place where someone was
trying to kill all of us every day
strangely like an addict
having withdrawals
i still missed the almost daily combat
for of the first four months of our
deployment
worse yet just as an ied does invisible
damage to marines
as it shot as its shock wave passes
through their soft internal organs
people in my orbit were suffering from
my injuries in the week before we got
back my mom was counting the hours
through sleepless nights at work her
inability to stop crying in a bathroom
stahl got her sent home for the day to
recover
when she met me in southern california
on return
she tried to talk to me about how i was
feeling
i didn't want to talk about it my desire
not to talk never really mattered where
my mom is concerned especially after she
took it upon herself to read my journal
from sangin
i was angry at the violation of my
privacy thomas i can't understand what
hop what happened over there because you
won't talk about it mom i'm fine
then please make eye contact with me
when i'm talking to you would you just
let it go
thomas you're my son and my best friend
you have been since you were born
it's like you're not there anymore
you're just this angry person and i'm on
eggshells i'm not letting anything go
what do you want to say to me mom i said
i'm fine
so
doing just fine huh
uh you weren't exactly fine
a lot of stuff going on
in the head
yeah i
undoubtedly
there are tons of benefits
of those experiences
at that time still a little bit raw i
think ultimately
we get to post traumatic growth
but
you gotta before you can get to
post-traumatic growth you've got to get
to gratitude and you've got to find a
find a way to be thankful
for that adversity thankful for that
hardship you got to get to your good
and um
you know
initially when the those
tough things happened you don't say oh
i'm so happy that this tough thing
happened you know if whether it's a car
accident or cancer you don't say i'm so
hap
but
the thing happened
and so at some point you can either
continue to be a victim of that thing or
you can take your agency back and say
good
and and and when you do that you can say
i am thankful for the the things that
i've learned from having this experience
and that's why you know i know many
amputees and
lots of and
this is the cycle you know initially
bitter
angry
uh but even the double amputee triple
amputee these guys i know
they'll finally get to a place where
they say you know i wouldn't trade that
experience
because of the things that i've learned
and benefited from
and the man that i am today because of
that and so you get to gratitude and
then you finally can kind of get to that
growth but undoubtedly in this moment
i'm still very
uh
hurt and offended i don't know offended
but like again there was there's felt
like there was some betrayal um
do this thing but then like i'd come
back in and be like why why are your
hands bloody
why why you got you know why so you got
a lot look it kind of seems pretty messy
out there
like
yeah you go out there and tell everybody
we go kill these guys go do this thing
and then when the generals come we're
like hey
sledgehammer kills everybody
and then you call me in and say oh
well you sure that guy had a gun
like
yes what are you implying sir like and
so it and and it's
and uh you just carrying too much weight
already to have
did not feel like your
chain of command has your back
and um
there were times within the company
where i felt
extremely betrayed and and so
uh yeah i think i was i was dealing with
that um
ultimately though i think
i was thankful
to have
porcelain toilets
uh california burritos
pretty girlfriend
uh san clemente doesn't suck you know so
like
a lot of things to be thankful for
at that time as well but still trying to
figure some things out and maybe not
doing it that well
uh
what was your like enlistment status at
this point like where were you at did
you did you come back thinking maybe
you'll get out did you come back
thinking i'm definitely staying in like
no i thought i was going to get out i
mean
i didn't know
i i didn't have this lifelong desire
to serve i didn't grow up as a kid
thinking oh i want to be a soldier
someday you know i didn't i didn't
uh
i never thought oh i want to be a
general or colonel or any of this kind
of stuff um i thought
i should do something and then i thought
i should be a marine i thought i should
be an infantry marine and then once i
finally figured out yesterday i should
be an infantry i thought i should fight
and i did that and i got the lead you
know the best men in this nation and so
i'd met my career goals and then uh and
with the amount of crap that i had
experienced i said maybe maybe i'm out
and so there's this thing called career
designation that you're offered as a
lieutenant and you've got to accept it
and i was not going to designate
um
because of i was really
disenchanted or just uh disappointed
with some of that company leadership and
so
uh i was going to get out i was serving
as an exo and an adjacent company uh i
got so is this when you get went to lima
company yeah
you know the frustration that you're
talking about like with the leadership
right how did you work through that
during the deployment
um
not
well i i mean between my company gunny
who ended up getting medevac and zach
like i i would say there were there were
times where i was on the verge of a
nervous breakdown it was never the
taliban
it was like i've been training
to shoot silhouettes of men
for years and now i'm shooting
and so like i am only happy when a
taliban is dead like i like that is no
problem uh
and i also am
not personally offended that the taliban
is shooting at me like i know that
that's what the taliban does they shoot
at us and so
uh i've been
training for that um
contact front contact left like i'm
training for the to be shot at and and
then like
marines get wounded
well
why do we have tourniquets on why do we
do tourniquet drills why are we doing
all these combat lifesaver and it's it's
all these things
you expect and if you're paying
attention and taking your training
seriously you expect that there will be
casualties that you will have to kill
people that you
and so
all that was okay and and when you go
outside the wire you're in the yellow
you know you're you're alert you're
scanning your baseline you're waiting
for that and so when you're in the
yellow and you're alert you can respond
to things fluidly adaptedly
but you leave the wire condition one
you leave the wire in full ppe flat
kevlar because you know you're going
into a hostile environment
when you come back inside the wire
condition four take your flak off take
because you're so now you're within
friendly lines
and that when you get ambushed within
that's where you're vulnerable and
that's when you can really get hurt and
uh
those moral injuries i think often
outlast
the the pain
um associated with with those with
physical injuries and so
what i did when i got back
to the states is i just ran i ran and
ran and ran and those fire breaks
outside camp pendleton
i just every morning i would just go
run for as long as i could for as far as
i could
and then i would just pour myself into
my work
as how i was dealing with things
how did you come to the conclusion that
you would stay in
i had a new boss and the new the new
lima company commander came in he's my
current boss uh
and
he was everything i'd hoped
for he was those ioc instructors you
know had such high standards and they
were so challenging they were so good i
was like man a marine captain
that's something that is a marine that
is really something and then i
found myself disappointed uh throughout
my work up in deployment
and disillusioned and then this and so
i'm i'm thinking i'm out
i'll go back to chicago going to be a
fireman took the took the firemen test
uh then this guy came in
and we want to be marines because we
want to do hard [__] we want to be
challenged we want and i wanted to be a
marine because they had higher standards
i looked at the navy i thought it's high
standards that's what i want
and this guy came in and he emulated all
those high standards and every day i had
to be at the top of my game every day i
had to get better and that's all i
wanted a leader who emulated
uh
what what he espoused a leader who was
accountable
and who held me accountable you know as
a lieutenant i had very little
oversight which in some ways was awesome
because i just got to go running gun all
the time out doing my thing but i needed
somebody to mentor me i needed someone
to hold me more accountable i needed
someone to develop me and
coach me and teach me and and he did
those things and i said
okay
well
i want to i want to do this what he's
doing for somebody someday and so i said
i'm going to stay in but
as we grinded towards the mew
i saw a flyer at the gym that said do
you have what it takes
uh come try out for recon and i said
yeah maybe this
exo staff life isn't for me i'm going to
try to go fight again with some troops
yeah the uh
i guess
no matter what industry you're in
whether you're in the marine corps army
um ibm
um
you know what what you name the company
you're gonna have some you're gonna have
some good bosses you're gonna have some
bad bosses
and and a lot of it has to do with what
i was talking about earlier like if
you're not doing your best to understand
the perspective of the person above you
in the chain of command
it's going to be hard and here's the
thing there's at least a 50 chance that
they don't they're not trying to
understand your perspective at all
there's a 50 chance that they just think
you should just be
conforming to what i'm telling you and
complying with what i tell you there's a
50 chance you got a boss like that
and in that case
you can't you can sit there and be mad
like why don't they understand or you
can say okay i gotta work with this i
gotta make i gotta i gotta make sure i
do my best to make them understand i
gotta paint a better picture i've gotta
do a better job and again it goes back
to you know that gives you some kind of
agency over your life to think okay
my boss is an egomaniac my boss has a
bad temper my boss doesn't understand uh
my perspective my boss is looking to you
know get promoted and that's the main
thing he's look all those things all
those horrible things
and we've all worked for people like
that
and you okay cool that's what my boss is
like all right here's what i'm gonna do
here's how i'm gonna build a
relationship with my boss here's how i'm
gonna build trust with my boss
regardless of what their situation is so
i'm just saying i like the fact that you
were able to
get to a point you say okay
you know there's good bosses there's bad
bosses out there
um of course everybody try and be a good
boss
try and support the people in the field
that's 100 it but when you're a
subordinate and your boss
is maybe not quite what you dreamed of
good challenge build a good relationship
with them
and and things are going to get better
um
that's the way it works
in the meantime you get married right
you make that deci decision you finally
say all right i'm gonna do this is that
before you uh screen for recon
it was before i screamed it was it was
right when i got back right when you
back got back you closed court wedding
yeah
to recon and you got some cool uh you
had an interesting day of
getting selected um for recon which was
actually pretty cool story won't go into
it now people can read the book for that
one
uh but you end up getting selected for
recon
but do i get do i have this right
instead of going to reconnaissance
school
they have recon on deployment or going
on deployment quickly and they say hey
you're not going to recon school you're
going to be an advisor
so the battalion was deployed so when i
showed up the battalion was deployed i'm
the one guy back one couple guys back
and they and i was supposed to go to
school and then it's called an ia an
individual augment came down and they
said hey
we need one
dude to go advise the afghan on how to
be recon
you're all we got uh even though you
haven't been to school you're gonna go
advise these these guys how to be and so
i joined an advisor team that was
mostly guys senior officers who are
going to advise like a brigade level uh
so like staff
stuff and and me and a recon staff
sergeant were going to go out and advise
the afghan recon company
so you've been back home for how long at
this point
i was home probably for about five or
six months when uh
i got the word that i was gonna get the
individual augment and and then you
july 2012 you go back to afghanistan
you're out at patrol base long beach
what was that setup like it was an old
artillery firing position it was just a
triangle tiny tiny little firing base
outside of marjah
and uh it was july and the human factors
if it like the human factors of the
first appointment was the
losing the guys and and the fighting the
grinding every day this was
i mean
not that i had any amenities really on
that first deployment but this
deployment i mean it was a cot a
cameonet a palette of water and
appellate mres
and that's it and i was living with the
a a
right downwind from their [__]
uh it was like the plagues of moses
coming through that place like
bugs coming through and waves blocking
out the sun i mean it was uh
it was hard hard living out there uh in
july and then yeah i'm going out i'm
fighting with nna and then i'm a i'm a
jtac so i'm like a freelance jtac so
anybody uh who needs the guy for an op
they're calling me and i'm getting to go
on some pretty cool ops how many a are
you out there with
about 50.
so it's you how many american advisors
the one other staff sergeant counterpart
and then we we'd pull like four or five
grunts from uh
the ao who would kind of help stand
security um
so it was very lonely so this is a
totally different kind of deployment
again the disparity of different types
of deployments you can go on is insane
for you to be out in the middle of
nowhere now
with a bunch of freaking afghans
oh god
um
did you so was your mission just to
train these guys up
yeah train train the afghan and partner
advise assist and then you know go out
with them on operations and yeah it was
but i mean at this point those guys had
been trained for a really long time so i
mean really i'm just kind of talking to
their leadership
and then going out on operations with
them
what's the op tempo light how often are
you guys going out we're going out every
day
but it's not reconnaissance type
missions it's like they're just
basically better infantryman than your
average afghan soldier and so but we we
really patrolled from like
2 a.m to 6 a.m because
by you know when the sun came up it was
over 100 degrees and so for the first
couple months it was just real early
morning patrols not too kinetic
with those guys
but again a company
going out would say oh we can have a
jtac just jump on this op and so when i
was jumping on these ops with the
different marine companies we were
getting it really getting into it
freelance jtac in in afghanistan um what
would you take away from a leadership
perspective on this deployment
uh leadership is lonely uh which i've
i've kind of already knew but it was
particularly lonely when it's you know a
couple of lance corporals
are the only other americans around and
so
you could only
talk about the things that landscape has
talked about
for so long and uh so
that was really a lot of time to think
by myself um
the you know one of the things that i'm
advising these guys and
uh they said one of them turns me and
says well you know when you leave is the
taliban's just gonna take afghanistan
back anyways and i'm like
what are you talking about you got a
whole army like you got 10 years of
training you got millions of
and
and i was like i want
afghanistan more than you want
afghanistan and
it's a really important lesson for me to
that you can't want something more for
someone than they want it for themselves
and
that applies to many different areas of
life and um so that was kind of hard to
to accept um
and i found that
i am happiest
when
i'm under fire and like it when when
when you
have a purpose and that is being a
warrior or lead combat leader
and you're good at that thing
there is nothing more rewarding our
sacrif are satisfying than when you get
to and so
got right back in the game and right
back in my first firefight and i'm like
okay here's what i know what to do like
you're going to do this you're going to
do that and so
um and then i was an enabler
and that was
a weird role for me because i'm not used
to being a commander and so when i'm the
jtac
i don't come i don't have command of
anybody i'm just there to support a
commander and so
it's tough because you see like here's
here's what we need should be doing but
like that's not your role and so like
staying in staying in my role
as an enabler was uh was was different
for me and so i got to appreciate maybe
that that role a little bit
um
you get orders go back to pendleton it's
now march 2013.
when you get home
it's safe to say at this juncture your
work-life balance was not in balance at
all
i just only did marine stuff
um
andrea at this point
she had
moved back to chicago yeah
um
one of your buddies
pulls you aside and is like um
do you do you want the marine corps do
you want marriage like which one of
these two things did you want because
they're mutually exclusive like you're
doesn't sound like you'd be able to do
both
um
you decide marriage
that's the thing you're gonna work
towards and
you tell your wife i'll get out of the
marine corps we can go home we'll figure
it out
um she says
nope not it i still don't want to be
with you
um
so this is a rough this is rough
eventually uh you get her to come back
she comes back out um back out here yep
um
doesn't
end up being
once again still not still not where it
needs to be with with her and you
eventually find out that
she'd been unfaithful to you while you
were on deployment
with one of your fellow marines
with
a marine that
that that live with you
um
how do you get through that
so i talk about ambushes that that life
is full of ambushes and um
you know like sometimes combat veterans
will try to say like oh well i was in an
ambush with with bullets and bombs and
and so you can and i'll tell you that
my worst ambush was that that was my
worst ambush in my life you know and uh
and so i tried not to establish
higher like everyone trying to compete
and who had it the worst or who and and
so and combat veterans think that we
have this or veterans in general think
that we have this special kind of
you know people should feel bad for us
because we did this like first off i
volunteered for those things
i wanted those things i sought those
things no one made me do that
um i was trained and prepared for those
things
i wasn't trained or prepared for that
and uh
and that
was a moral injury that took
a long time
uh and maybe still presently one that um
you're you heal from
and you know
i
much of my motivation in life is a
response not to repeat the same
mistakes that i experienced when i was
growing up and and one of those was
divorce and so i thought you know no
matter what i'm not going to get
divorced
uh
but at that point um
i thought yeah this this is uh this is
over
and um
i want to just make it very clear that
uh ultimately that
um
that
those actions from my wife uh are not
representative of who she is as a woman
uh and that she has been the greatest
blessing of my life um outside of my
savior and so
i wouldn't be here today without her
but i was hurt i was angry
uh
i lost my mind a little bit uh i went
crazy you know i i not like crazy like
yelling or screaming or
uh but just kind of went on a bender of
doing unhealthy
[__] um for a long time
but through it all uh
i
dated and
did whatever but they're always inside
me
i
i was so happily married and i was so
much looking forward to starting a
family and there was no one else
that i wanted to be the mother of my
children there was no one else that i
wanted to grow old with there was no one
else i wanted to do life with more than
her
and so even though i met some great
people along the way and had a lot of
fun along the way
at the end of the day i'd always come
back to thinking about her and so
i kept trying to stuff other stuff into
that and uh
and finally i said you know maybe you
stop
trying to force
and and
and so she had been so forgiving with me
and so graceful with me and so merciful
with me and
uh
i have
gone wayward
many many times and um
yeah and i finally called her and i said
yeah
let's uh
let's try this again
uh
which was probably the best decision
ever made because now i've got the most
uh beautiful loyal devoted wife and most
phenomenal mother to my three children
and so
i messed a lot of things up in life i
think um
doing a re-attack on that was uh
it leads to some really interesting
conversations at ipac you know that
you know uh when you go to the s1 or the
admin and they're doing your s1 audit
they say like do you ever get divorced
and you're like yes
like okay who's like who'd you divorce
and then like
are you remarried i'm like yes and like
okay who's in it like
and there's nothing miss lance
corporal's like
oh i i uh just keep pushing let's
corporal just keep pushing
yeah no i i mean again i'm only reading
a small part of this book and you give a
lot more background on the whole
situation on
you know you take ownership a lot of
your behavior
um and i think that's
you can kind of as i read the story i
was like yeah well that's to be you know
you can see it
and then even the reconciliation you can
see it as it's as as it's being put
together um that you had to
square your [__] away um and and that's
what was able to you know allow this to
happen
um but again i i think it's just like
man i mean the seal teams has like a 90
divorce rate it's like it's like insane
because of all this stuff you're gone
you're it's just it's just it's just
mayhem i don't know what it is in the
military at large but it's really
freaking hard on relationships really
freaking hard on relationships so
um
i think it's just the way that you spell
this stuff out you talk about it is
really important it's gonna help a lot
of people
win when they're going through this kind
of thing so um appreciate you putting it
in there
um
2014 winner you're assigned to the
school of infantry you're gonna you're
that you become the director of of
combat instructor school so what does
that exactly mean
so the school of infantry is where uh
all the privates come after they go to
boot camp and so if you're gonna be a
non-inventory marine you go to a course
called mct where you get like six weeks
of basic inventory stuff or four weeks
of basic and then if you're going to be
an infantryman you get three months of
your basic
you're a rifleman machine gunner uh
mortarman and so
and then from there you go out to your
unit and so that the combat instructors
are the ones that
receive those
privates and pfcs and train them in
their in their their craft it's also
where we have all the advanced infantry
schools so if you come back as a squad
leader to go to the advanced squad
leader advanced machine gunner
the combat instructors are the ones
bringing the squad leaders in and
teaching them the advanced tactics and
so
but before you can
be an instructor there you've got to go
through a course
comment instructor school and then you
go out and you train the privates or you
train the sergeants and so
i was the director of that school which
was uh just a phenomenal position
working
with the highest caliber sergeants and
staff sergeants uh in the entire marine
corps and it was really really
uh refreshing and good for my soul to be
around 20 to 25
dudes who are at the top of their game
every day and just doing grunt [__] uh
it was it was a great time and were you
teaching as well i did a little bit of
the platform instruction but uh i was
more like the principal and and mine i
had combat instructors who taught in
combat instructor school and so you know
hike with them go out on the range oh i
see the range
do a little class here and there but
generally uh
my instructors did the bulk of the
teaching i always feel like you learn so
much when you're an instructor role and
i was very very very lucky to
have been in that role quite a few times
i was an e5 man i was in e5 teaching
immediate action trails
and you've learned so much man you're
detached you're watching it happen you
see that officer that's looking down his
gun instead of looking around you're
like hey what are you doing and by the
time you're in that time i was at a
position like it was freaking awesome um
to have been through that from a
detached perspective because you're
watching it over and over again
uh
sir you're doing that meanwhile zach is
carrying on by the way um and again i'm
i'm zach's not here we're we're we're uh
not reading much of his story but he's
he got married he married a woman named
diwa is that right diwa
uh they're having kids
um
he he
graduates from a school
of course the taliban still gaining
power
um and that's not good for him not good
for his family 2016 they're they're
receiving
night letters which are just straight up
death threats from the taliban taliban
to kill him to hurt his family kill his
family anyone that helped america i mean
it's like a nightmare for him
he decides to apply for the special
immigrant visa program
um
that's a long
process still not even complete for him
to this day so
uh
he gets poisoned
at some point loses his pancreas
so he gets poisoned he's you know his
guts hurting he goes to the doctor the
doctor's like hey they're they're
poisoning people the taliban's poisoning
people
uh lose it like i said loses his
pancreas i mean it's just
horrible uh
meanwhile still no still no real
progress in um
in his siv
you know to get his visa to get over
here
meanwhile you are going through your
career you take command of lima company
third battalion fourth marines um lucky
lima
so now you're kind of back in the game
back to leading troops
uh you're gonna go on
a
deployment was it was the whole
deployment plan for australia yes
damn i never i i when i was in the
military man
uh the the guys talked about australia
as if it is like the promised land
heaven and i never went there until i
retired
uh and it is it's
it's freaking amazing um there's a place
called noosa have you ever heard of this
i was there yeah
there's not too many places in the world
i would move to like tomorrow afternoon
but that's one of them the freaking
waves there they've got like the most
incredible waves
there's a place in california called
malibu i'm sure you've heard of it
there's like
10 malibu's in a row
like all just different little spots and
you can walk walk down you ever been to
uh the san diego zoo the one right here
in downtown yep
it's all like uh all
really manicured these nice paths and it
just looks like this is like the most
like like jurassic park scenario you
walk around this thing at noosa is like
that it's like you're on this jurassic
park beautiful nice little trail and
then you're just watching these
beautiful beautiful waves um
so you're going to australia
uh your company commander how
how was that how was that how do you
like being in command again
yeah i when i was at school of imf tree
i there was one regiment seventh marine
regiment which is out in 29 palms and
they were the only ones doing the
special person magtf so they were going
to iraq afghanistan syria
and so i contact the monitor and i say
hey i want to volunteer to be a company
commander because i know my time is
coming up i don't want to go out to
seven marines
not a lot of people volunteered to go to
29 palms
and so within like 30 seconds he writes
me back he's like you got it and this in
the monitor is like a person who's
always impossible to get a hold of you
know you're right
and this is this instant instantaneous
you got you want 29 palms no problem you
got it man
uh i'm like cool he's like you're gonna
go to three four i'm like okay cool
uh and then i find out that
they're not even a
they had deactivated because of force
cut structure and then they had
reactivated so there
there's only an h s company of three
four right now and i'm like okay
and by the way they're going to
australia and so i call i call them on
her back and say hey
i said i want to go to tournament palm
so i go on one of the deployments to
iraq and he's like uh you said 29 pounds
you got 29 palms gotta go yeah
and uh so i was initially a little butt
hurt uh but ultimately yeah australia
doesn't suck uh there are worse places
to be deployed and so
had a good time there um
company command was awesome i mean
company command was awesome it's just
just savage aggressive
out 29 palms just attacking shooting
[__] blowing [__] up and
uh great lieutenants great platoon
sergeants great squad leaders i mean
just
an aggressive company aggressive work up
uh
it's it's an infantryman's disneyland
out there you know and says every day
you get to go do great infantry training
and so uh workup was a blast it was a
great team i was very very fortunate to
have the team that i had and then uh
yeah we had a good time in australia any
any major leadership lessons learned
there
a whole lot um
for sure i i think
i become
very obsessive in how i approach
training
and command and
it's because at a very
young
age
i gained a great appreciation for the
consequence of this profession
uh that there that it's not called duty
there is no responding
and that when these kids are dead
they're dead forever
and that the hole that is left
is felt
for eternity
and
and having had that shape me that's that
so that's how i approach everything that
i do is like i will not stop until i
know that these marines are as lethal as
possible and had the best opportunity to
come back to their moms you know and
their wives and their children and
and so
push
push and um
also i'm very competitive and so like i
want to be the best platoon i want to be
the best company i want
and so
when with with that in mind you know we
were the main effort company uh we got
uh during all the big exercises and then
on deployment we got to go to queensland
and i got to be become part of a uh
australian battalions
that my boss where the rest of everybody
stayed back in darwin and so it's like
staying in indiana or being in malibu
you know so it's like uh you want to get
and so
uh
it queensland is much nicer and and i
was a senior marine in queensland
so a lot of this like was pretty good
but i didn't have
all that came at a cost
where i drove my marine so hard that uh
i burned them out
uh i pissed them off
um
and i could have had a more harmonious
approach to leadership and
i look at you either you're either i'm
either looking at you professionally
or personal as a person but not both
at the same time and so if you come into
my office and you you could be anybody
say hey sir this my mom got breast
cancer okay whatever i can do to support
you right now how can i help you like
you have my undivided attention i care
about you how so i i will still treat
you very much like like you're my son
and and
uh
but outside of that i'm just
i i'm ruthless like i don't want you to
be sorry i just want you to be better i
don't want your excuses i just want your
results
uh the solution is generally just work
harder and be more aggressive and so
i drove
you know redlined the cup and that's a
long workup a long deployment and by the
end of it um
i'd really
wore out a lot of those marines and i
think i i think i could have had a more
harmonious approach to leadership and
tried to at least
keep them
humans and marines kind of a little bit
at the same time but
uh so i you know
if i have an opportunity to be a
battalion commander i think i'm going to
try to be more mindful of
of that
yeah it's definitely something that you
you uh
a lot of these great leaders or
allegedly great leaders or even
mythological leaders that we have in the
military
you you you see that's the that's the
thing that shines through about a lot of
them um
that you don't see on the surface but
when you read about them or you read
their books like chesty polar like oh
this is just the ultimate hard ass but
when you read about him and how he
treated the troops and how much he cared
about them
um you know hackworth the same way like
like the hardest dudes you could ever
imagine and yet they would completely
know when they were pushing too hard
pull back the reins get protect their
guys from stupid [__] and like that's
why these guys were so
totally beloved by by their troops
because they the troops want to get
pushed hard but they don't want to do
dumb [__] and they know and they're then
they're humans and they need to get
treated that way so that's uh definitely
some great advice for anybody that's in
a leadership position in any scenario um
yeah you want to push hard yeah you want
to win yeah you want to do better than
everybody else
and one of the ways to get the most out
of your people is to treat them like
people
um
you come back from that deployment
is that when you get you actually get
remarried is after that deployment yes
so you get remarried um
all's looking good
you are
now driving across country get your next
set of orders and i'm gonna i'm gonna go
to the book here um you're driving
across country
now i had a lot to think about
i'd been to war twice
i had married divorced and was about to
remarry the same woman
i'd commanded a company of marines
and the marine corps had seen fit to
select me for a promotion to major
i was now a career marine on my way to
spend three years molding future navy
and marine officers this is when you're
heading to the naval academy via some
schooling
as i crossed our nation
i visited the graves of nine dark horse
marines
where and when i could i visited their
families
they were still living breathing men to
me
they certainly were to their families
as i began to turn my thoughts to
training and educating future officers i
felt it critical to visit and reflect in
the presence of some of the men who had
made me
who i am
corporal tevin
nguyen
sergeant jason pedo
pedo
lance corporal alec catherwood
first lieutenant robert kelly
first lieutenant william donnelly iv
corporal derrick wyatt
lance corporal arden banagwa
first sergeant christopher carlisle
and sergeant matthew abate
all about
sergeant pedo and first sergeant
carlisle died in sangin
sergeant pedo made it back to walter
reed hospital in maryland before he died
first sergeant carlisle survived his
wounds the day
that
the day zach and i watched from a
distance then got promoted retired and
was killed in a motorcycle accident
i owed him much of my sanity while in
sangin
i needed to tell him that
mata bate was the heart and soul of
three five
a recipient of the navy cross the second
highest award for valor presented by our
nation
his death in combat stunned every marine
in the battalion
he was a scout sniper who spent much of
his time in support of kilo company
he was
the one
the one of whom heraclitus spoke the one
who will bring the others back
no one was cooler than a batte
no one cared more than a bate
he was the author of the gun fighting
commanded commandments posted on the
wall at pb fires and now inscribed on
the back of his grave marker
quote
thou shall never leave the wire without
bandana containing at least four inches
of slack
in any situation
thou shall blaze
nothing matters more than thy brethren
to thy left and right
thou shall protect no matter what
when going out in a hail of gunfire
thou shall pop them nugs until the body
runs dry of blood
and
look hella sick
um
i found a newspaper article about um
abate it said
sergeant james finney 25 served with a
battery in sangin
when he heard of his friend's death
he had the same reaction as many of the
marines in the battalion
how do we win this war without him
um
as your
[Music]
driving across country
as you're stopping by
gravestones as you're talking to
families
how is your perspective
changing
these gold star families um
are incredible
and the loss for them
is as present
today as it was the day they lost their
son
and um
the pain doesn't go away
and
we have a collective duty and
responsibility
to carry their son's legacy forward
and to do everything that we can to
honor their sacrifice
i have a personal responsibility to
honor these men
and how i live
and uh and a responsibility to the
families
and so
um
you know tevin
nguyen was killed december 28th
his son
he'd been there for the birth of his son
right before he deployed and
that was it
and uh so going to see little tevin
junior
art of banagwa uh his first generation
american both his parents immigrants
um
was killed when he was 19.
he was the
of that engineer squad attached tequila
company he was the the 12th marine that
was
injured or killed
and i got to tell this family like
your son is my hero and your son is the
reason i'm alive
and that everybody in his position
before him who was walking point through
a minefield
either died or lost her limb and your
son when he was 18 years old still
grabbed his pack grabbed his rifle and a
metal detector and walked out in front
of us
never once turning to me at 18 years old
and saying sir can somebody else take
this responsibility
my son
is his namesake
and uh
the idea that these men knew the
consequences ahead of time and win
anyways and that if you told them how
the story ends every single one of them
would be right where they were fighting
next to their brothers
mata bate
when he got his navy crossed they the
squad leader got shot and one marine
goes to help the squad leader he gets
blown up the corpsman goes to help the
marine that gets blown up he gets blown
up the next marine goes help the
corpsman he gets blown up
finally everyone recognizes we're in the
middle of a minefield and every time
somebody moves
they're killed
so people stop moving
it's a normal thing to do
everybody but one marine
and he runs and he treats all the
casualties he coordinates the medevac he
grabs the metal detector sweeps the lz
doesn't not train to do that just proofs
the minefield with his feet repels the
enemy calls calls in that
helicopter um
yeah
and so when i talk to these these
families it's um
it's so heavy
uh but it's so important
and um
i just thank god that uh men
like this
lived and that i had and just for a
little bit just for a moment i got to
know them
and uh not only did these men
die well but they lived well
and they're meant to celebrate
and
and i it is my lifelong duty
to continue to honor these men every
opportunity i get
that's it
i know i i eventually told uh mark lee's
mom a story about mark
very similar to what you're talking
about so
i start off by telling her that in
vietnam like the point men would rotate
because
your walking point you're going to get
ambushed you're going to get blown up
you're going to hit a tripwire and they
would rotate those guys
and
in ramadi being the being in a lead
vehicle you're the one that's going to
get blown up you're the one that's going
to hit an id
and uh
especially being the gunner you know
well now you're not in any any armor and
you're just um
totally you're exposed
and
we'd line up the vehicles
and and markley you know he's a new guy
and so guess what he is um
turret gunner in vehicle one
night after night and and when you leave
the gate at ramadi uh when you when you
drive towards the gate to go out into
town there was a uh
vehicle graveyard and there's like
75 or 100 vehicles out there and they're
ever just twisted and gnarled they've
all been dragged back
and every one of those vehicles
represents
one two three four five casualties
wounded killed you know just just
heinous and that's what i don't know who
the
i don't know who the hell decided that
was a good place for the vehicle
graveyard but it was a shitty place for
the vehicle graveyard because that's
what you saw and
same thing with mark man
never asked for somebody else to take
his spot
some heroic dudes
for sure
and did it with a smile on his face i'd
i'd go how are you feeling hey mark
what's up man how you feeling and like
his favorite response he liked to gamble
a little bit
he'd say i'm feeling lucky sir
um
so that's the guys we get to work with
now
this you're taking all this with you
to
be
um
a professor at at the naval academy
which is a pretty
i mean you're you've got all this
awesome combat experience
i know awesome might not be the right
word but you've got this real experience
and
you're going to take that back now to
the naval academy how did you how did
you end up getting that billet how did
that billet end up coming about
yeah i think it was a mistake um
i uh
i was deployed to australia and i said
you know when's the last time you read
any fiction all you do is read
biographies and
uh you used to be in high school you
were smart you liked to do ap literature
you let your kind of as you pointed out
nerdy
uh and then progressively got dumber
through college and uh um
maybe try to read a book that isn't just
uh
and so
i googled
popular works of fiction and the first
one that came up was great expectations
by charles dickens
i read that and i said oh i like this
and um
a message came out we said we need
someone to teach english at the naval
academy
i know anything about the naval academy
not academy guy
i'm not an english major uh failed
english and uh i said well maybe that's
me
sounds like a good pick
and uh
so i'm a guy that you know shoot your
shot and uh put my head in the ring and
yeah clearly the marine corps needs to
refine that selection process but uh
they they picked me um
and uh before i knew it i was at
georgetown
uh in a m.a english ma program get in my
ass kicked
not qualified to be in that program
i should have been in the t-ball league
and i showed up at the all-star game how
how long how long was that course of
instruction so it's supposed to be a
two-year program marine corps likes to
keep the morning tight so 12 months so i
did 12 2-year program in one month or 12
months so
yeah working on a compressed timeline uh
been in the fleet at that point for 10
11 years
and so
just
through got thrown in the deep end of
the pool uh didn't know how to swim
but
it was an incredible experience it was
it was experience i really needed
because i very much was just a hammer
and that's all i knew and i had no other
tools in life and
studying literature and writing and it
really uh it helped me work out a lot of
things that i'd not
unpacked yet
and uh
so i i knew i was going to be outside of
my comfort zone
i didn't know quite how out of my
comfort zone i was but i was i was
outside of it and uh from like
orientation
to when we're going around the table
where i think you just tell people
what's your name is like i'm tom french
caller like no from orientation i was
already out of my depth uh through
conclusion uh but i had a great i had
some great friends that i met there that
helped me and i had some great
professors and um
so yeah then i a year later i show up
and i start teaching english and how was
it when you showed up at the naval
academy had you ever even been to the
naval academy before no i couldn't even
told you where the naval academy was
when i applied for that position
uh just uh
i just thought i what i thought is like
they're gonna pay me to go read books
and then i gotta write a little book
report on it like that's what i thought
like an english program would be
and then we're having these discussions
in class and i'm like what the hell are
these words like this is supposed to be
english and we're using all these words
i have no idea what anybody's talking
about like we're doing this close
reading and literary analysis and all
this kind of stuff and
um
but yeah i got up to annapolis it's
beautiful
and
it was an
awesome awesome job these midshipmen
were hungry they're good good americans
and
i got to pick my favorite books
and then talk to talk to them about my
favorite books you know so we're doing
fields of fire and matterhorn and gets
firing starship troopers and
uh
and so
that course was not offered when i went
to when i was an english major yeah i
didn't get to do any of those books
unfortunately and uh so
yeah teaching these midshipmen poetry
and composition and
[Music]
but i was teaching a little bit about
leadership
literature i was teaching a little bit
about composition and i was teaching a
lot about leadership
in the classroom and
it was a super rewarding tour and uh
really really enjoyed my time there
now one thing that you talk about in the
book is as you start
as you start teaching
justin justin mcleod who's one of your
marines
uh
dies of an overdose
and
in the same month
two of your other marines
die by suicide
you
at this juncture
um
ask for and get
counseling professional counseling
what what did that consist of
and how did it
help you
so
mcleod wasn't my first marine that that
i lost to the war after it but mcleod
was
tough in a lot of ways um
i just
i still have a hard time coming out of
the yellow you know getting into the
white and being vulnerable and and but
when i would sing
my daughter to bed and she was one years
old at the time i'd always try to just
be real present vulnerable with her and
seeing you know this little light of
mine with her and then i just finished
that and then i come to my room and one
of my marines from singing so say gotta
call me
and uh
mccloud
he had he had shown up to 35 in 2008 he
had gone on the iraq deployment he'd
gone on the mu deployment and so he'd
done our work up but then
he was going to eas he said you know i
thought i was going to extend but i just
had a son
i'm going to i'm going to ease and i
said you know you're my best shot you're
my best nav guy like
uh i know you just had a son but um
we really need you so
do whatever you need to do and if you
want to ease but i hope you extend and
he comes back and says you know sir
you're my family too
a few months later um
the engineer steps on the pressure plate
the mcleod is over the charge and they
both get
hit and um
i'm about like five people back and as i
come up uh
as i come up one of my marines hands me
mcleod's fingers
and uh i look at mcleod he's missing his
arm
and uh his legs and
like uh i it was teague and i said
thanks teague
and now i'm in this like weird position
i have these body parts with a body part
that doesn't exist anymore i put them in
my cargo pocket
and uh
my engineer's going into shock
so i all i have is my frog top so i take
my i take my blouse off i wrap him in my
blouse and i've got nothing on under my
flat jacket and i go back to mcleod and
initially he's like real calm and cool
uh he's smoking a cigarette saying like
kill these mothers you know whatever and
and
uh but we're having a really hard time
landing the the medevac burden there's
there's probably five or six guys all
working on them
uh when you've got an amputee it takes a
couple dudes to patch up you know each
thing and so
what i would always do is the first
thing is i would take a junior marine
off and once i had security set once i
had the medevac in motion i would take
that junior marine off so that they can
hold security and i get my hands in that
marine's guts and so
but it was dusk and
they were having a hard time telling a
laser or smoke they couldn't they
couldn't see where to land and so
and then every time they'd come in that
zone would get hot and taliban would
start shooting at them and so they keep
waving off
and uh
mcleod starts to succumb to his wounds
and um
and i i said ioc and the marine corps
training is is just so good it's
phenomenal it prepares you to do the
things technically and tactically
uh
but there's nothing that can prepare you
to have a conversation with a guy
who you convinced to extend
who said i'm going to get out because i
want to teach my son
to play baseball because mccloud had
high school scholarships our college
college had to go play baseball but he
enlisted and said
and i'm saying hey you got to stay here
for desmond
because someday
you're going to teach him how to play
catch and you get and
and knowing that
what is he going to be able to do you
know he's got no arm no legs
and he starts a flat line
and i just like
everything in me
wants to cry for this marine but
everybody's you know as a leader like
you said everybody is looking at you how
you're going to respond to this thing
and
and i got to keep trying to talk to this
guy about finding that will to live
again for his son
and uh very um
and the will to live is a powerful thing
and he stays and he and
and but he he never stopped fighting
that battle and ten years later um
and claimed him
and uh
and so
yeah that's what got me on the the road
to pb abate but it also
i was still
very destructive
in my tendencies and my thoughts and my
actions
and uh
and my family was the casualties
and so i was still fighting the war
myself in a lot of ways
and being selfish
and being harmful
and uh
my family was the one suffering
and um
you know i i thought oh i i just
push push push that's how i deal with
everything you push
and uh
but you got to look at this as
we know how if if you are
if we we do a really good job of
teaching our marines and sailors how to
treat
casualties physically if you're if
you're routine we know it's self-aid if
your uh priority is buddy aid if you're
urgent it's got to get to higher echelon
of care and so if you've got us a
sucking chest wound we say we got to get
you to the dock
we don't say just hey you got a second
chest when you probably just
patch this up you'd be okay no we said
we got it but what we don't do is say
like these invisible wounds are your
routine are you priority or you're
urgent and so
um
you know if you're routine
and you're just having a bad day that's
normal everybody has sad day funky day
whatever and you just whatever whatever
you got to do put on the jocko podcast
go for a run you know you get out of it
you know
if your priority you need some buddy hey
i'm going through this thing you share
it with your buddy you know your buddy
can kind of fire to firemen carry you
out of that thing and you but sometimes
you got a sucking chest wound
and talking to your buddy or or going
for a run is
those are helpful
uh but they're not going to heal that
wound and and i've been
bleeding for a long time uh but i lacked
the self-awareness
uh
to be able to triage that when i also
lacked the ability to and so i needed to
go to it just like if i had a second
chest when i want to go to a doctor i
need to go to a doctor and so um
yeah i uh
i finally uh
went and
and there's a cpt cognitive processing
therapy i think it's called and and what
it does is
it
brings you to the traumatic event
over and over which is a super dangerous
thing to do by yourself
you know you can't you don't those are
all
volatile
and you need a trained professional to
open up your sandbag
and start to
unpack and pull some of those things out
and uh
and through like that repeated exposure
you you start to kind of
be able to negotiate or navigate that
and and so
my wife
says
and i'd have to distrust her judgment
that that was uh
what saved me in a lot of ways saved our
marriage and um
so yeah i uh that that was
kind of how i ended up there and it was
it was it was very helpful how often do
you go
well i went for about nine months while
i was at the naval academy um
and you know you're supposed to do
i don't know 12 15 20 sessions of this
cpt uh and mine got a little truncated
because i got orders at the naval war
college
um and i haven't been back uh
but it's at least to a point where it's
i'm not i don't think i'm an urgent
casualty right so i think uh
so probably still benefit from it but um
yeah and and it's it's one of those
things where it's the self-delusion
where you just say oh i don't have time
for it i don't have time for it i got i
got marine sleeve i got
it's like man if you don't
get to the root
cause of some of the stuff that you're
doing
you're gonna
so
make it a priority
and also mostly by the way you're just
scared
of dealing with it and so you're making
excuses
because you don't have the courage to
deal with the tough stuff that's going
on inside you and so
um
yeah that's uh that was kind of my
my experience with all that
you mentioned really quickly
that you established
um
a charity organization called patrol
based abate pbabate.org
and that was in november 2020.
what's the purpose behind that yeah so i
i
i've always been like
a person that if there's a problem
you should walk point like you should
try
to figure out how you can contribute
and uh
i said this suicide thing whatever's
whatever we got going is it seems to be
not working
and uh so i said let me go read all the
va suicide reports so i pulled up you
know 10 years of va suicide reports and
what i kept coming back to is that the
leading possible cause of veteran
suicide were feelings of
disconnectedness and isolation
so that veterans who are disconnected or
isolated
are are more vulnerable
to suicide
okay
and then
there was a little stat that kept
showing up that was really surprising
and that there's no correlation between
combat and suicide and veterans
and that
people
generally have it like what really and
that was my same reaction and and
but as i thought and reflected on that
when you transition the thing that
you're missing is that tribe and that
purpose
and
you can find that in other ways jiu
jitsu there's plenty of ways where you
can find that chai find that purpose
again uh but it
not everybody is able to fall into or
find that thing and and i think
when i think of a uh
an air crew on a c17 or c130 when i
think of a motor t crew or com section
everybody in that unit
has
said i'm willing to die for you
and everybody in that unit understands
that um
keeping aircraft flying is like that's
an important
keeping trucks rolling like that's
important the ability to communicate
important so everybody when you look at
a mission a mission is a task and
purpose and so the military quite
literally issues you a tribe here's your
squad you're in first squad
uh and then they and then they give you
a mission which which actually has a
purpose built into the mission statement
um and so then
as you transition there's this identity
crisis because over your left heart
there you've got a name tape that says
navy marines you know and it's like we
just hand you a piece of paper and say
you're not that thing
you say well man i still i've been
indoctrinated into this thing
and there's not a process of
indoctrination in out of it
um
and
and so i said what is out there that is
getting people
if if isolation and disconnectedness are
the two big risk factors here what is
out there that's getting all veterans in
community and getting all veterans
connected because it's if it's not just
a combat
[Music]
veteran problem
and what i found is like the
overwhelming majority of veteran service
organizations out there and there were
many
are dedicated to supporting our special
operations our wounded and our goals our
families
and i am so grateful
that as an american that we recognize
the people who've made the most
sacrifice our special our navy seal
foundation our green beret found like
i'm so happy that we say these people
have paid the most cost they've given a
limb uh they've deployed seven ten
twelve times by special forces uh their
goal so i'm happy that that's where
we've resourced and put and invested in
because these people deserve it
um
but what the data tells us is that
there's there's more to this picture
and so
i didn't find an organization at the
time that i felt
was inclusive or accessible to everybody
that's raised the right hand
and i wanted and there was always some
kind of barrier to entry said you know
uh you gotta you don't you're not
disabled enough
to to be eligible you're you're not uh
you don't have enough of a disorder you
haven't been to combat enough you it's
it's always this barrier or check this
box check this box
uh and then
or they're like really very reactive
i've overdosed i've had a suicide
attempt it was right to bang now now
that you're right a bang and that that
you're in your moment of crisis
now you're eligible and i said well
let's what's preemptive what's proactive
what's left of bang in this and i didn't
find a whole lot
and i i said let's create a space
where your service is your price of a
mission
that that you don't i can i can check a
lot of these boxes by the way
uh i don't want to be defined by
disorder or by my disability or by you
know i i just want to say hey i'm
tom and i could use some community and i
could use some connection and so
we went and we got 350 acres up in
montana
and we said uh we're gonna do the things
that you like to do veterans so what are
the things that you want to do well
let's build around a shared common
interest so we've got a fight club that
does jiu jitsu we've got a strength club
that does powerlifting we've got a music
club that's been up there we've got an
art club that's been up there we've got
a book club that's been up there we've
got a hunting club that's been up there
and so a lot of these organizations are
predicated around
fishing for example and i think that's
really good uh a lot of healing could
happen during that not everybody
is in to fishing you know and so like
you you you and so we want to say i want
to say hey
if it was up to me i'm a grunt who likes
to read so like i like to hike and i
like to read books and so like i would
just have pbotted be like the hiking
book club uh but that's not everybody's
thing and and so we want to say whatever
you're into
uh if you're willing to walk point
we'll resource you and we'll build a
club or
club around you and so uh and we're
gonna and we're gonna fly you up to
where where our dojo is it's on the side
of a mountain in a montana river valley
there's no more beautiful dojo in the
world to roll than on the side of that
mountain in the pibate there's no better
place to to lift weights or and so
uh
and we fly you out free of cost uh we
pick you up we feed you all free of cost
because it's it's all this idea of so
many veterans especially guat veterans
and or post 911 veterans are conditioned
this thing where
well i was just a
and they use this just
and and and we've we've really i think
largely through social media constructed
this hierarchy of what it means to serve
and if you weren't
in ramadi or if you weren't part of this
organization or you like and it's this
weird competition of in this red
definition redefining of what service
means it's like no
service means you raised your right hand
you swore into the constitution you did
that for four years honorably that is
what services by definition
and so
uh you serve something greater than
yourself and uh and so we want the
airmen the sailor the soldier the marine
the national guard the reservist
active duty pfc if you if you raise your
right hand you're eligible and you're in
no additional call and and like many
people when we would say this they're
like wait me well i'm just an a nope i'm
just an airman i'm just a motor t's like
nope we actually built this place
for you like for me well i would go but
i can't afford it's like oh good because
it's free cost oh i would go but like i
don't do that it's like what do you do
well let's go do that thing and and so
uh we've run two we call it the return
to base program uh we've run uh two
summers of it
and uh you know the pillars are getting
around the fire um because i really
think that connection forms around the
the fireside chats
uh getting out in nature because i think
i believe good things happen outside and
then getting back into service and so we
do a service project around there and
uh and then we sustain that through
local chapters and so
um we just say like
uh
what sandbag do you want to fill we need
somebody to walk point and uh
we created this space for you and uh we
got a big tent we got a seat for you at
the table come on get in community get
connected and uh that's what we've been
doing and it's been uh pretty incredible
to be a part of it how many people have
you put through in the two summers
about 150 people uh up to montana
and then um
we're still running another program this
fall
and you know if we can't do the thing
that you do on a side of a mountain i'll
find a way to support you so so somebody
said hey i'm in the
scuba diving
can't scuba dive on the side of the
mountain so okay so i found a partner
down in the bahamas and we're going to
send 15 veterans out in october and so
about 150 but people who have been
through um our local chapter programs i
mean it's thousands right and so every
month all around this country you've got
pb avatar new york boston orange county
san diego austin meeting and getting and
getting into community and getting
connected and so uh
it's been pretty awesome to
to watch it grow and um yeah
yeah that sounds awesome and uh if
people want to support it they go to
pbubate.org to support it that's the
best way um
so
get trying to try to follow the book a
little bit here um by summer 2021
meanwhile while all this is going on
zach in his world is falling apart um
in afghanistan
the taliban is
taking over
um
time is short
again you detail a lot of stuff in the
book but uh you go into like full
combat mode but administrative effort
to get zach and his family
out of there um
and you're going down i mean you're just
you're taking every everything you can
possibly do to get this done social
media fundraising
senior military leaders uh politicians
to try and get something
going to get him out of there and of
course
this is no small task because at the
time there's tens of thousands of other
people that are also trying to get out
of
afghanistan
as all of this stuff as it starts to
fall apart
um
and and just to give a little bit of
zak's perspective here
um and again i i'm fast forward there's
so much so much more detail in the book
get the book
uh
this is from zach on july 16 2021 when
tom told me i needed to get to kabul and
explain why i had to stop and sit for a
moment i was relieved that more people
than just tom and i cared about the
survival of my family but i knew chaos
was coming
i just needed it to be still before it
began i just needed to be still before
it began
even when you've been planning for it
the thought of leaving your home forever
is overwhelming
how do you say goodbye to your family
members when you know you may never see
them again
how do you kiss your mother for the last
time
how do you keep from forgetting the
smell of her hair after you do
i sat on the terrace of our home
where so many of the simple things at
the center of my life had happened
childhood marriage my children taking
their first steps
they were moments as tied to a place as
i was
now i was being forced to leave them
behind with my home
for all my sadness there was no hiding
from the situation
life for regular afghans was bad and
getting steadily worse i was living in
hiding the taliban's messages which had
long made it clear they were looking for
me and would kill me for working with
the americans when they found me were
growing bolder and coming more often
i could not live in kunar i could not
survive there more importantly my family
could not
when i learned that the americans left
bagram in the middle of the night on
july 2nd
i thought about my own times flying in
and out of there i remembered how the
air base felt like it could not contain
all the planes and helicopters it seemed
like america's power was without end
i had placed my faith in that
i did not see then how the americans and
our government would ever let the
taliban come back
but here the taliban taliban were
leaving me messages at my family's
doorstep
during the night
so it was just awful for him and um
at this point the book kind of
kind of turns into a suspense espionage
spy political thriller it's it's mayhem
but it's not a novel
it's what's really going on
and what's really happening to this real
person and his real family
and and one thing that's cool is
the way this the way the book is set up
it's telling it both from your
perspective and then you hear his
perspective and you hear hear your
perspective
as you're trying to coordinate this
movement and link-ups and bona fides and
messages and
like
dying batteries on cell phones right
which you think you know when you're in
a first world problem you know oh no my
cell phone died and i'm not gonna be
able to get a message until i get to my
car and get it charged right
um you know he's out there his his
battery's low and he's
literally standing at the wall trying to
make calms
um
it it's it's
it's a crazy scene and again we all i
mean everybody watched this on the news
but to hear somebody that was on the
ground their perspective as they're
trying to escape this is zach again
at the airport wall so he's at the wall
trying to get into the airport
a taliban fighter stood closer to the
wall and was watching the crowd an ak-47
hanging across his chest
he saw us looking up at the american on
the tower roof he looked in the same
direction and reached out to alert his
friends i saw him look up at the
american again i could tell they made
eye contact with each other
the talib put his pistol put his hand on
his pistol grip of his ak the american
reached towards his hip but another
american standing on a half wall below
him reached out to grab his leg he shook
his head no
and the one on the tower moved his hand
away from his hip the taliban below made
their hands into the shape of pistols
and pointed them at the american as he
carefully climbed down and stepped back
over the wire
i kept my eyes focused on him i could
not see his face
i did not know if if it was major jared
lefevre is that right lefevre
major jared lefevre but i felt in my
heart that this was the moment then i
saw him lift his hand to his mouth and
speak into a phone
a message arrived on my own
in in the group chat with tom and jared
the text said put your son on your
shoulder
i lifted my son over his head over the
shouting sweating mass of people he was
wearing a bright blue shirt
as john shattuck had told me to have him
do early that morning
the american waved me closer i grabbed
my family and we fought through the
crowd to the base of the wall with our
new friend following
as we pushed
my countrymen aside i was nodding at the
man i knew now as major lefever
he shouted me do you have your family
yes i yelled back and one more
major lefevre turned to the three
americans next to him all large men and
heavily armed i could not hear them all
talking but from their gesture i could
tell they were trying to decide how to
pull seven people up and over the wall
they began to they begun to attract
attention from more of the taliban
drowning people will reach for any hand
they see the crowd was beginning to move
toward the base of the wall below where
they stood the americans finished
conferring and began to move
my eyes were locked on major la fever
as he sent me a text we have to figure
out how to get you
to us at the door to your left
um
and and that's the way this book goes uh
reading through this it's it's
it's agonizing and you just
you just don't know
how this is gonna end um other than the
fact that the title of the book
indicates
um
that
you know we have to keep the faith you
keep the faith zach keeps the faith and
ultimately
the uh service men and women on the
ground
remain faithful
and
zach
does get through all kinds of gates and
wickets to get him and his family out of
there
um gets out before the attack at abby
gate
um
which happened a few days after he left
where
we lost one us army soldier one u.s navy
corpsman and 11 united states marines
um
perhaps the last
to die for that particular cause in that
particular nation by that particular
enemy or
perhaps not um only time will tell
but zack made it out and and made it to
america and
um
i mean it's it's very powerful and it's
very powerful to hear his
you know his perspective
let me just give you a little bit of
that this is when he's back i was
willing to risk my life
thousands of my fellow afghans lost
theirs
i worked for my people and country in
pursuit of a better future for all of us
but i also worked with and for the
americans because they came
to help us build a better afghanistan
i would do it again
i would still sacrifice my myself for my
country for my people and for america
the country that saved and welcomed me
and my family
too many good people died for a dream
for me to ignore the obligation to pay
it back
the taliban were not our only problem
the corruption in our own national
government was a chain around our
collective necks
leaders must earn their positions by
deserving the trust of the people
a government with anything less will
never survive and the governed will
never thrive too many of our leaders
bought their way into power as a means
of enriching themselves too many
warlords held on to power by force
placing themselves ahead of the people
they were supposed to protect
it was a frail system that fell when the
foreign support holding it up ceased to
exist for now the taliban own
afghanistan the afghan people are again
living in a nightmare
people i love who are still there are
suffering
they are starving with no food and no
money with which to buy it
modern medical care is already only a
memory
security and freedom are a dream
when they seize the nation the taliban
claim that former members of the
security forces and people who worked
with the americans would be safe in
italian taliban regime it was a lie then
and it is a lie now
the executions and torture have already
begun
i knew that was coming
the taliban told me themselves
[Applause]
and you know those statements about
afghanistan and the leadership really
apply anywhere and corruption and
nepotism and arrogance and power your
hungry leaders are the downfall of
any organization any team any company
and uh any country
and we have to definitely be aware of
that ourselves
and pay attention
when was the first time you saw zach
when he got to america
i flew out to minnesota to to see him he
had been in a refugee camp in virginia
i think it's fort pickett for a while
and uh kind of tough to get down there
or get into the camp and and so
he'd been maintaining all along that he
wanted to go to texas because his
cousins were there and important to
assimilate with family uh his cousins
had also been interpreter and got here a
couple years ago and so he was under the
impression that he would get to texas
until uh about 24 hours they said you go
to minnesota tomorrow in january
and uh
you know minneapolis in january is not
uh texas and so um
he was in a kind of bad spot and so i
flew up there got to see him got to see
his family and then
he had been waiting for like a work
permit and it's better if you stay
within the resettlement
process
because if you pull out of the
resettlement process
you kind of get reset back to zero
and he had just received that work
permit about the day or two before i
showed up to minnesota and he told me i
got my work permit i said
so do you need to be in minnesota he
said
no i said let's go to texas
uh so the next day we were on a flight
uh what was it seven seven passengers
eight bags four car seats with a layover
in denver
uh but
we landed in uh san antonio that night
and um
it was good to see the mission through
and what's he up to right now
he works construction hanging drywall at
a cancer hospital six days a week 12
hours a day and he just uh
but he just had a son while we were in
new york together so two weeks ago he
had a son and so now uh
sajad is his fifth kid and uh
american by birth
um
i've been
having some great conversations with the
vietnam guys and
and some vietnamese that came over
you know after the war
and uh
just their
their work ethic
and what they instilled in their kids is
just amazing
and um you know
when you you hear about zach
like hanging drywall 12 hours a day it's
like th this guy's gonna make something
happen like
he is gonna make something happen
um just just an awesome story of of
you
know just the the unceasing uh faith
that that you two had in each other to
make this happen
um
so
where are you at now
i'm back at 3
get some
uh get some legit model right where do i
try to research where that came from
when they start saying that uh
in iraq is is where it
jack so uh they were they did they were
in phantom fury alfajr and uh
and so
yeah i'm dark horse three and i'm the
operations officer for three five so
we're uh
training and uh getting ready to deploy
next summer
you deploy next time or any idea where
you guys are going pacific ale pacific
ao get some
uh
i
i guess that kind of brings us up to
present day right yeah um
probably a pretty good place to wrap it
up i know you got some marines to go
lead um
what do we miss
no i think we got it
for people
for people to find you first of all um
the book uh always faithful
it's available anywhere um order it
we'll put a link to it
right echo charles yes sir we will we
collectively will do that so people can
find it and get it
uh
patrol base abate that's your your
organization yeah um
go and check that out uh pbabate.org
uh
i found like a kick-ass little video of
sergeant abate too it's like 30 seconds
long
i don't know if there's any more video
if there is please let me know
he could just tell he's just like
like
whatever percentage of charisma of
whatever percentage of just being a
badass uh that's freaking legit
um you're on instagram yep you are at
kill
dot
zone but it's spelled funny
z
zero so it's z
and then
a zero and then an n and then a three
so
at killzone
is where you're out on instagram um
echo charles you got any questions yeah
how'd you crash your motorcycle back in
the day
i crashed it twice
your mom really hates you yeah
because i tried to go too fast too soon
and uh so about lost my thumb
and that's when i kind of retired from
just sort of randomly or was it like a
very specific incident where you know
you made some raw specific wrong
decisions yeah too fast in a turn and
laid it down okay
everyone that i know that has a
motorcycle or had a motorcycle has
crashed in
varying levels of injury or whatever so
that's kind of the thing yes
uh
i like you know i mentioned mark lee
like in a gamble i like to gamble
and man the odds
when you're riding a motorcycle the odds
are just not your favorite for
for being okay when when whatever
happens
happens and it's happening oh yeah
that's what it
i mean that i don't know every single
person in the world with a motorcycle
but every single person that i know that
had a motorcycle crashed in including
myself by the way
and i didn't even own the motorcycle i
had my friend's motorcycle for the
summer i laid it down uh-huh so it's
like but in my mind when was that
college
but you didn't get injured no
i handled but i still understood what
kind of bike did you have did you have a
super bike do you have a harley i had a
my first bike was a victory and then my
second bike was a ducati okay yeah that
ducati gets way tempting doesn't it i
mean that thing just wants you to roll
yeah it's almost like one of those
inevitable slippery slopes well correct
me i don't know everybody's different
to a degree where
you go fast and you're like you kind of
feel the power a little bit but you
don't want to push it and then you kind
of get kind of be like i can't go faster
i can't go fast and it just never stops
right until you crash and i move through
that progression very rapidly
well we're going to um we're going to
support your mom on the anti-motorcycle
gig here fair enough
tom any final thoughts no sir
well hey thanks for joining us today
thanks for sharing your lessons thanks
for your continued service with the
marine corps
and thanks for keeping the faith with
your interpreter zach
who never let you down in the field and
you did not let down when he and his
family needed you and uh
to everyone out there right now that's
still holding the line
i recommend we remember the guidance
from sergeant matt abate
in any situation
thou shall blaze
nothing matters more than thy brethren
to thy left and right thou shall protect
no matter what
until the body runs dry of blood
thanks tom
thank you
and with that tom schuman has left the
building
echo
i would say you know when you when you
reflect on
just talking about
tom's first deployment you know he's a
platoon commander
there's just so much responsibility and
that's what's that's what's good if you
know if you if you've been in the
military
you've you've had so much responsibility
that for people in the civilian sector
out there
you hire someone to run a branch or run
a manufacturing facility and they've had
this much weight
there's a really good chance that
they're going to have some good lessons
learned and and being able to do a good
job it's just
a lot of weight is on the shoulders of
these young
young soldiers sailors airmen and
marines out there a lot of weight a lot
of burden on these young guys and it's
it's it's look this is this highlights
the story of an officer but
the young
the the young corporals the sergeants it
just
really is
an incredible thing that we send these
young men and women to do out there on
the battlefield and
i'm glad we were able to capture some of
these lessons and share them
and um
yeah so there we go so
thanks again to tom for coming down here
and to three five for letting them come
down for the day
uh appreciate everyone's support for the
podcast um if you wanna support the
podcast and you wanna support yourself
you know get yourself some of that jocko
fuel
get yourself some of that jockofield.com
have you tried pink mist yet yes how do
you like it i like it it reminds me of
it doesn't remind me but it's similar to
like the orange where it's like you
i'm not saying you can't go wrong
because of course you can go wrong but
it's one of those ones where it's like
just it was good but i just wasn't
surprised that it was good you know it's
like that kind
uh yeah so we're talking about new
flavor of discipline go it's called pink
mist it's like a pink lemonade scenario
it's kind of hard to make the word pink
sound cool but when you put pink mass
probably might be the only way to make
thing
sound cool pink mist
so there you go that's our our energy
drink
here's the thing
this is not normal energy drink there's
no chemicals in there
there's no sugar in there it's literally
good for you
so go get some joco discipline go and
it'll really help you out in life i
think it was you doing a speech to a
group of people it might have been life
i don't know
i've been at origin at the camp maybe i
don't know i don't know either way
but here was the po here was one of the
many points where there's like there's
companies where they'll be like hey
let's make an energy drink and they'll
be like okay so what are we going to put
in this energy drink because we got to
sell it yeah i'll tell you what they're
going to put in whatever the consumer
will want right now yeah so it was and
what's cheapest
yeah so you and you made you said this
more eloquently than me but i'm gonna
i'm gonna say what i really gathered
from it and it was kind of um like it
was it kind of haunted me a little bit
where you have a company that's like
okay let me make an energy drink what
are we gonna put in it okay let's put
some caffeine in it for the energy right
so okay cool caffeine we'll put this
much in however much right he goes okay
but we gotta preserve it or we gotta
make it taste good we gotta you know
cause they we gotta get them to drink it
right sure
seems seems like oh of course you gotta
get them to drink it add sugar but so
let's put sugar okay so sugar wait we
want it to be we want it to be really
good though more sugar more sugar
and you know okay so i and even at this
point sugar is like cool like that's
nothing new you know
oh i don't know let's put like some
other stuff some chemicals some
preservatives in here some stuff that
and then after a while these things
start
adding up right all these little
ingredients and it's like okay has
anyone ever thought of like wow what
this is gonna do to like a you know 17
year old kid or a person or whatever if
they drink one of these every day which
is kind of the goal man if they if
everyone drink one every day that'd be
freaking awesome right as far as okay so
has anyone taken taken account for like
what if these people are drinking one of
these two of these every single day like
what's going to happen to them oh yeah
we did that but like we don't care about
that we just want them to drink them
every day oh what if what if like what
if it's really bad for
and what if it causes maybe some death
oh well we don't care about that you
know as long as we're drinking them
every day kind of a thing and that's
kind of the picture that was kind of
painted there was like bro that's true
that's true it's 100 true and they can
they cut the corners on the costs
our drinks like three times more
to make well i think in some cases four
times more than some of you than what
what some of these other companies are
putting their drinks yeah and if they
cut costs that means they pay less for
it that means they get more money when
you you know like so it makes
it's weird because it makes sense on one
hand but on the other hand it's so like
sinister you know so nothing sinister on
our side only goodness only the goodness
the goodness of monk fruit yeah
we put some caffeine in there not too
much though yeah but just 95 milligrams
but we got some nootropics in there make
sure you get all the energy that you're
gonna need so there you go get some
chocolate fuel get some milk i've been
on the mulk train lately yeah peanut
butter be honest with you
binge is going hard in the paint with
peanut butter
it's so good it's so good it's
ridiculous
uh so chocofuel.com you can also go to
the vitamin shop
vitamin shop has pink mist by the way a
little exclusive scenario going on with
them right now and also you can get the
stuff at wawa hey by the way okay rtds
ready to drink milk milk yeah it's out
there it's a protein
meal it's a protein dessert it's a
protein provider of goodness to you
and it's ready to drink it's so funny
how like we had like a little stockpile
like a pre-sale stockpile at camp and
they were like oh this is we'll have
enough just for the campers and you know
just not no well we what we thought was
we will reserve multiple pallets it'll
be more than enough
to last one week yeah
dude people went ham because once you
taste one you're like i'm gonna have oh
i'm gonna have one for breakfast one for
lunch one for dinner i'll put them in my
season everyone in my cereal it's all
good we're freaking drinking this stuff
twenty four yeah that's like two days
that's like two days yeah like two days
and that was it yep so we
uh we are on the path just trying to
produce as much of the ready to drink
mulk as we possibly can right now to get
it out there because it's delicious and
it's freaking good for you yeah
yeah so good
good so as many as you want uh yeah
that's all jackalful.com speaking of jiu
jitsu
originusa.com we're making jiu-jitsu
geez
we're making jeans
we're making boots we're making hunt
gear
hey the delta 68 has new colors or
something like this yeah i saw like a
picture a little thing yeah yeah
the the
one of the wash houses which is like a
giant
machine a series of machines
that can wash things at a high rate so
they get like
worn they get broken in
yeah
is that the traditional way because you
know how you have a lighter color jean
then you have the freaking dark dark
it's called the wash house now wash
houses are really hard to build
and we have one
but ours wasn't working but you know the
team down there in north carolina has
been busting their ass getting the wash
house back up and running we had to get
new machines had to get them installed
put in there
um and now we have like the original
wash house from the golden era of
american textile is back up and running
i think we're playing bro we're not
playing no no i don't think we're not
playing no you're not are you gonna do
acid wash remember acid wash
i feel like acid water
that right there is up there with like
hair metal to me i don't like it right
yeah it's weird how acid wash at the
time was freaking awesome by the way no
not me i never liked it it was awesome
in the time but i don't have any
pictures of me wearing acid wash jeans
or uh affliction t-shirts interesting
remember when affliction was all wild
and all the companies had all the weird
designs i have a few pictures of us and
you have it it's not affliction but it's
like in that direction but it was like
throw down because a lot of people was
following they had one that was a little
bit and also you know what my
my caveat here is i did wear some
walk-out shirts like for a specific
fighter for a specific camp for a
specific fight which i can't remember
may or may not have been straight up
just like cheesy affliction
but uh luckily for me i i didn't own one
so no you weren't there are pictures of
me at the club represent remember the
affliction uh jeans do that like weird
they go hard man very hard those
afflictions you take something you know
i think the genes were acid wash you
know yeah they weren't but you know you
know the book the dichotomy of
leadership yeah you take anything and
you make it an extreme it can become bad
yeah so if you take like genes and
there's like thread on them but then you
start going crazy with it it turns bad
yeah you get if you put a pair of jeans
in a wash house and they become like
comfortable and a little bit faded
that's cool but then you put like acid
on them and they look all weird that's
not cool you can't take stuff to an
extreme i understand
and that's why they kind of stuck in the
80s where you went hard and it was like
freaking out they jumped on the trees
coming back right apparently yeah yeah
because there's a show called stranger
things which i have not watched but my
daughter's or yeah one of my daughters
is into it but and do you think 80s bro
okay and am even me just starting to say
ask this question
i feel like you're probably one of the
last people to ask about this or maybe
one of the first i don't know but do you
think that like you know things always
come back right the retro and it comes
back and
you know all this and fashion is one of
those ones but
isn't there always like one two three
things that are like that's two hardcore
80s that that'll never come back yeah
that's true but here's an interesting
thing first of all the 80s in my mind it
seems like it was a few years ago
but it's like 35 years ago
so when i was a kid
60s stuff right 60s and 70s like
things were like hype
but that was only i mean this is in the
80s for me so they're only like 15 years
old and they were still hype yeah you
know what i'm saying
so
it's weird that we're talking about
things that are coming back but it's
been 40 years since the 80s
yeah it's just straight miami vice
activity going down yeah did you like
miami west
uh yeah here and there but i guess that
was kind of a big thing
some guy i used to work with at the
valet used to say like oh you're tubs
from miami like oh somebody did a uh
uh photoshop of you and me as crabs uh
tubs and crockett and it looked legit
yeah yeah yeah
they did a good job
they did a good job of that that made me
laugh and it you kind of i will say you
kind of get a little bit of tubs going
on that's what they said i did i didn't
gather that at the time but hey cool man
if more than one person i you know lend
it some weight all right uh so there you
go so no acid wash no acid wash so we
will prevent that from happening right
now uh also drop the story documents
door this one equals freedom if you want
to represent
with a shirt a hoodie
what winter what fall right is it fall
right now in winter you know got some
hoodies on there discipline equals
freedom
standard issue sure he's on it's rolling
oh the standard issue speaking of which
layers layers but people are
representing currently as we speak so
yeah look out for that also we got the
shirt locker which is the subscription
people are representing that hardcore
yeah i'll just see random people oh
that's actually
that's the locker again full-on
supporting yep you get a new design
every month
they're new they're creative see if you
can recognize them um yeah supporting
appreciate the support and subscribe to
the podcast also also we have jock on
the ground we just recorded a couple of
those well yesterday yeah so that's
where we answer your questions directly
we also cover some
some subjects that i have been coming up
with i you always
give me some subjects
i feel a little bit bad because so far i
think we've done one of your subjects
out of 50. yeah
so i gotta open my mind a little bit
more you know
accept what you're putting down
maybe also i'm not seeing the vision
like you're putting some you know we
should talk about this thing yeah and
i'm not really i'm like thinking what
the [__] what is this going to get us i
know yeah and i have to figure that out
about you like what is it exactly that
goes through your mind that that says
okay i could talk about this versus i
won't um because here's here's a i'll
think of something or i'll come across
them or something will be presented to
me and then i'll be like hey that's
interesting i wonder what jaco would
think about this so then i'm like oh
i'll like write it down i've never
gotten that vibe from your suggestions
i've only gotten like what is
i've this gotten like why is this
interesting yeah i know you'll be like
talk about something and i'm like
i don't understand how that's good so
we'll do one of my subjects
okay
are you disappointed when you get the
notes and you're like oh he didn't pick
my subject again you feel like you're
spinning your wheels and wasting your
time no i never do i never do but
disappointed sometimes you know maybe
here and there because
sometimes especially the list that i
just sent you some of those were just
like a threat that popped in my and i
just wrote it down so and i just which
one is the best one
best one the best idea that you have had
oh i don't know i'd have to look at it
bro they can't be that good of ideas if
you don't even remember them i think
they're all pretty good
i thought they're all pretty good oh uh
here's here's one i don't know if it's
the best one but like the difference
between um like pain and suffering so
it's more like the it's like the concept
i mean and maybe i won't put into words
as good but the idea that like you know
when you feel pain the natural instinct
is to be like oh it's pain so avoid it
but then every once in a while you have
a certain type of pain that you know is
not
like damaged it's not damaged you know
it's like whether it be for a good cause
or it's more for like construction it's
just like like if you know when you lift
weights now so when i was a little kid i
used to like do push-ups or whatever and
then the next day my arms and chest
would be sore and i used to hate it
because i didn't know what it was i mean
oh i don't want that feeling i don't but
then when you realize what part of the
process it is
you kind of like now as an adult and
we talked about this before offline or
whatever where
when you have doms you kind of have like
whether it be from jiu-jitsu or lifting
you kind of have a better feeling
because you know you're sort of in the
game so it's like you won't avoid that
anymore in fact it's kind of like a so
what's the difference like where's the
difference you know and and can you just
flip it over mentally see i'm saying
there's a certain pain you can be like
oh this sucks wait a second wait a
second you know what i'm saying
i think i'm starting to recognize why
these subjects are again
so i picked the subjects most of the
time they've done some good ones
i mean open mind you know i'm gonna put
out a list of subjects that i thought of
and i'm gonna
see if people want to vote on them and
then i'm going to open the bottom of the
list for suggestions do that that's good
uh yep so you can that's jocko
underground.com it costs eight dollars
and 18 cents a month if you can't afford
it just email us assistant said
underground draw at jackunderground.com
because we got to have a place that we
control because right now we don't
control the platforms we're good with
the platforms we get along it's fine but
you never know when things might go
sideways so
we have a youtube channel as well we've
got psychological warfare we've got flip
side canvas bunch of books hey check out
the books check out the book always
faithful
by
tom schuman and zanula zaki
um available we'll have it linked in the
thing
um
only cry for the living by holly mckay
check that book out you want to hear
about the war in iraq up close and
personal that's a great way to do it
and then i've written a bunch of books
of course also of ethnofront leadership
consultancy where we solve problems
through leadership so many problems
let me rephrase that all your problems
in your organization are leadership
problems that's what they are so
if you're having issues inside your
organization it's because
you have issues with your leadership you
want to fix them go to ashlandfront.com
come and check out what we offer all
kinds of different things from
leadership consulting to events that we
put on
all through that we also have a an
online training
platform
because just like
trying to
get in shape you can't just go one time
to the gym and think you're gonna get in
shape you gotta train every day so
extreme ownership.com if you wanna come
and
check out our
online academy
if you wanna support patrol base abate
go to pbabate.org
so support
what tom's got going on there for
veterans and if you want to help service
members act and retire their families
gold star family check out mark lee's
mom mama lee she's got an incredible
charity organization
if you want to donate or you want to get
involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org and
heroes and horses micah fanc up there
he's in the wilderness right now on a
horse with 40 other guys
and they are finding themselves in the
wilderness
and if you want to check us out on
social media
tom schuman is at killzone
zero n three
and for us on the twitter on the gram on
facebook echoes out of withdrawals i
am at jacqueline
watch out for the algorithm that's
trying to get you and
thanks once again to major tom schuman
for his service in the marine corps his
continued service in the marine corps
thanks for sharing some of those lessons
here appreciate you coming down thanks
to three five for cutting them loose for
the day to come down here and share some
of those lessons and to the soldiers
sailors airmen and marines that have
given their lives so that we can live in
free freedom
we are forever indebted to you
and we will not squander
this gift
and also to our police and law
enforcement firefighters paramedics emts
dispatchers
correction officers border patrol
secret service all first responders
thank you for your sacrifice to keep us
safe here at home
and everyone else out there
there's one more
thing in the book and
tom mentioned it briefly today uh
it's something that sergeant matt abate
scrawled
on the wall of his patrol base in
afghanistan it said simply
someone must walk the point
that means someone has to be out in
front someone has to take risks someone
has to make
things happen someone has to look out
for threats someone has to guide the way
someone has to move forward
and it seems like
sergeant abate was talking to all of us
and he wasn't just talking about war he
was talking about life
so go out there
and take a point
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out